Tick tock, Tom Rock. Good evening, good
morning, good afternoon to everyone
who's watching from all over the world.
It's your friendly neighborhood
philosopher here, Dwood. And uh with me
now, I've got your uh friendly
neighborhood historian, Raymond Ibrahim.
How you doing, Raymond?
>> How's it going, David?
>> So, you've uh caught yourself in the
middle of uh the Nommo cult recently.
>> Yeah, I finally understand. I finally
understand what I'm dealing with. I kind
of uh was I stepped into it rather
ingenuously thinking something else, but
um I'm starting to see it is in fact a
cult.
>> It is weird. And and uh guys, I I say
that because I I started calling a cult.
It's they have all the characteristics
of a cult. And a cult, keep in mind a
cult, I mean to be fair, like a cult is
normally something that is like
compromised on all the basic doctrines
of of something. But uh when I when I'm
saying it's a cult here, it's like using
cult tactics and cult methodologies to
give people a cult mindset. And uh
conspiracies, conspiracy theories tend
to have the same effect on people,
psychological effect on people that
being in a cult has. It's you've got
this special knowledge and everyone else
is outside of it. They don't have this
special knowledge. And well, if you
present this special knowledge to people
and they reject it, then it's because
they're evil. they know it's true, but
they're rejecting it because they're
against the truth and they have ulterior
motives and so on. And so, uh, yeah,
when someone when someone usually, um,
signs on with a cult, then that's that's
what they end up being. And it it's the
same with a lot of conspiracy theorists
is we've got the special knowledge, the
there's other people who they either
don't know or if they if they're
familiar with it, they're evil. And
that's what we're finding about
ourselves right now.
>> Yeah. And of course there's the faith
element amongst cults. And it seems that
you know this no moeri saying that
Muhammad didn't exist has taken on it's
become sort of a tenant of uh their
faith. In other words, if you attack it,
you're attacking a tenant of their
religion. And that's how it's become
which I didn't realize at first. And
that's why um they respond so
irrationally and with so much vehement
emotionalism because you're basically
they see it as an attack on their faith
just saying that Muhammad existed. And
of course you prove you're a horrible
Christian. you're actually a Muslim. I
of course am a Muslim. Um, and we're all
helping Islam undercover. So, it's it's
it's pretty bizarre stuff which I'm only
now trying starting to appreciate how
how deep this stuff goes.
>> And you're just so everyone knows, he's
not exaggerating when he says it's like
becoming a tenant of faith. It's like if
you are not on board, you're not a
you're not even a Christian or you're
some uh you're an evil Christian at the
very least. And we're going to be
checking out some of that. Part of me
wants to zoom in on you more because I
have zoom feature here so I can zoom in
on your head so that we're the same
size. But I don't want to cover up. No,
no, no, no. I'm saying but no, because I
could do it right here. I could do it
easily. But I also don't want I don't
want to cover up your guns. You know
what I mean? Because that's part of like
the im the intimidation factor.
>> What you going to do, brother? All
right. That's a shout out to the
Hulkster.
>> Hey,
>> I used to be I used to be a
Hulkcomomaniac at the time when
Hulkcomomania ran wild, you know, like
87. I was like uh 14 or 13. Uh that was
the first generation of Hulkcom.
>> You don't have to tell me that was the
greatest by the time it was uh I
remember it was because they had
Wrestlemania 1, they had Wrestlemania.
Wrestlemania 3 was where it really
exploded and you had uh Andre the Giant
versus Hulk Hogan and stuff.
>> Body slam.
>> Yeah, I was Well, it was weird because
my my favorite was Rody Piper. My my
favorite was Rody Piper. Yeah. But uh
yeah, I love the way he was always trash
talkinging and stuff. But um
>> uh how why how were we talking about Oh,
we were talking about your we were
talking about your guns. Yeah. So notice
if we wanted to argue like them, right?
if we want to argue like them. And guys,
we're going to see this. We're not
exaggerating. In fact, we are we are
understating how bad this is. Um, every
single thing we say, it's for some
ulterior motive. We're getting and I've
seen that we're being paid
>> um we're being paid by wealthy uh oil
rich Muslims to defend Muhammad's
existence because if if we don't defend
it, then Jay Smith will completely
destroy Islam with his powerful uh Nommo
arguments. I've seen uh it's because I'm
being paid by Israel, so Israel's paying
me to defend Muhammad's existence. Um
because if I don't know why they
wouldn't want uh Islam wiped out by um
by Jay Smith's powerful arguments and so
on, but there's always there's always
some sinister motive. Um it's
>> and mine is very obvious. I'm just
Ibrahim, so I I was always a clandestine
Muslim and now the truth's come out. Now
everyone knows what I've really been up
to, which is, you know, defending
Muhammad.
>> Yeah. Yeah. So now now the truth is out.
He's defending and we hear that too.
We're like secret we're secretly helping
the DA guys and trying to uh trying to
prop up Islam and um we're we're trying
to get uh Muslims who left Islam because
of the powerful case of J Smith. We're
trying to bring them back into Islam
even though I've never seen a Muslim
leave because of these arguments. I've
seen I've seen thousands of Muslims
leaving because of the problems with
Islam. But uh but yeah, so we're we're
we're working for all sorts of uh really
really terrible people and that means
we're just uh we're evil. But notice if
we wanted to argue like that, if we
wanted to argue like that, it'd be very
easy. You know, Jay Smith is jealous of
Raymond Ibrahim's big muscles and it's
giving him an inferiority complex and so
that's why he's lashing out at at
Raymond and so on. It's like, who would
think that is like not the dumbest thing
they've ever heard in their entire
lives? But we could if we wanted to go
in that direction. Fortunately, we are.
>> They're desperate. That's why they do.
That's that's why their argumentation
has just devolved into such, you know,
caricatures. I don't they don't have
anything else as we're going to see.
>> All right. So, um yeah, before we before
we jump into we got video clips, we've
got uh tons of screenshots of comments
from the uh the Nommo uh fans. Um why
don't just for anyone who's new here,
why don't you give a a little background
into what you've uh spent your life
doing and so on and basically how you
got into this uh this particular topic
recently. Okay. Uh yeah, I've been doing
this stuff for uh probably 20 years. My
first article published I think around
2005. And I've just been uh you know, I
studied it academically, Islam and the
Middle East and the medieval era,
especially history, the Arabic language.
Worked at the Library of Congress for
many years. Um
focusing on that field. First book came
out in um 2007, the Al-Qaeda Reader.
been writing books since specifically
really focused on history lately
including um the mo most popular ones
probably Sword and Scimitar 14 centuries
of war between Islam and the West which
gives a broad overview of the historical
conflict. Um I'm actually the truth is
this is the irony. I'm so not interested
in Muhammad. Um Muhammad was sort of
like the entrance thing. It was the fun
child's play back in the early 2000s for
me learning about him. And then I
decided, okay, now it's time to kind of
move on, look at the actual history of
Muslims century by century. Um, and and
we'll get to how I got suckered into
this, but um that I've always found that
much more um I think telling rather than
always, of course, talking about
Muhammad is important, which is why you
and I are doing it. But um I anyway and
so I continued and and that's
essentially what I do now is mostly
write the books articles and I got my
little YouTube channel which uh I've uh
basically been working on um this last
year and it's growing and I'm happy
about that. Um and yeah, so how I got
into this is because um I would write
articles or I'd make videos or in my
books I would still have to mention
Muhammad once in a while, right? even
though I talk about usually events after
his life. And it would just never fail.
There would have to be someone who comes
crashing in hysterically, always in all
caps with exclamation marks screaming
about how I thought you were smart. I
liked everything you said up until you
got to Muhammad and proved how dumb you
are. And then it would follow and you
haven't read what J. Smith says and or
you haven't watched J. Smith. Everyone
knows Muhammad never existed. Are you
crazy? Okay, so that started happening a
lot and originally I would just ignore
it and I've always been familiar with
the skepticism towards early Islam and
even the claims of Muhammad never
existed and I just never bought them for
various reasons. So long story short, I
decided to make a video which I cut in
two parts. Um just to clarify to people
because a lot of these attacks that
would come to me would be also polite
sort of like you know you're doing
really well but uh we want to politely
inform you that you need to learn more
about how Muhammad never exists because
we we saw you mention him as if he was
real. Okay. So I wanted to make clear to
people yeah I understand the arguments
and I just don't buy them. So yeah to me
Muhammad is real and I talk about him in
that sense. And then at the same time, I
explained why I believe the Nomo
position is so futile, especially
against Muslims. And we can get into
that, but I think you already know it's
it's really the the weakest PMIC. And
the reason it's the weakest pmic is
because as I explained in those videos,
the questions that we're dealing with
and the reason this is such an annoying
and vexacious non-stop thing is because
the question of a person's existence or
non-existence 14 centuries ago will
never be answered. Okay? Not just
Muhammad, any historical figure. You
can't, we will never definitively be
able to say Muhammad or anyone from
1,400 years ago or even a thousand years
ago or even five 600 years ago say that
person didn't exist or that person did
exist. Okay? And in order to get a
Muslim to believe that, you better you
better concretely prove it without a
shadow of a doubt. But it can't be done.
And I'm not saying it can't be done
because uh Muhammad did exist or didn't
exist. We it's just the discipline of
history. If you know how it works and
the historical method, that can't be
done. And I'll even give you an example.
I know you believe Muhammad existed.
What if I were to ask you, what
hypothetical evidence would you need to
finally join the no camp uh the no camp
um group? And my point is, but as you
think about it and and give me an
answer,
>> I can already give it
>> is that
>> you you have an answer?
>> Oh, yeah.
>> Okay, let's hear it.
>> Okay. Oh, yeah. First, I just want to
clarify because uh uh there are people
who uh uh tend to misunderstand things.
When you're saying you you can't prove
um something from 1400 years ago, what
what you're saying is like prove it with
with certainty like this basically
mathematical certainty.
>> Yeah. Yeah. So, uh history is basically
probabilistic. You're always arguing
based on probabilities and so on. And so
you're saying there's no scenario where
>> certainty though to get a Muslim to
believe you is what I'm saying. Not
probability.
>> Yeah. That's that's the thing. It's like
whatever case you think you have, um,
it's never it's never going since you're
dealing with probabilities and it's
never going to be enough to convince a
Muslim that Muhammad didn't exist and
therefore why would you why would you go
down this road? Yes.
>> Or even to convince me or even to
convince me as a non-Muslim because a
lot of the the bottom line is whatever
evidence a person can show whether it's
a coin or a map or what something
written or not written there is always a
hundred responses to it. Okay? And uh
that's why in my initial videos I said I
don't even have to know Jay Smith's
arguments to know that I can disagree
with them because I know they can't have
there's certain truths which are like
mathematical truths. Okay. And if you're
a Muslim or a Jew or a Christian or an
atheist, you believe it, right? Radical
Muslims and Christians all agree 2 plus
2 equals 1, four. They all believe we
need oxygen. They all believe we we need
food. Okay, that's because these are
concrete incontrovertible proofs. The
questions of history will never reach
that certainty. You're right. Of course,
there's probability, right? But be
without certainty, then I don't need to
even know your argument because I
already know that the primary sources,
which is the most important thing when
you're doing history, support the
existence of Muhammad. So just because
someone can now delve in and look at
maps and coins and make arguments,
that's not any way that's not any kind
of proof to overthrow the primary
sources, which is what someone like J.
Smith um does. But if you can uh so to
give you an example, I was thinking to
myself, what's the most powerful
hypothetical proof to show that Muhammad
didn't exist? And one thing that came to
my mind,
>> I had my answer too, but go ahead.
>> Okay. Yeah. Well, you give me yours.
>> Okay. Yeah. Mine was if you asked what
what evidence could be what evidence
could be giving would would sway me over
to that side. Um it's pretty
straightforward. I'm not thinking of any
particular evidence, but I think in
terms of uh inference to the best
explanation, like what is we've got
here's all the evidence basically all
the evidence that's in front of me. What
is the best explanation of this
evidence? And if uh it it's not just
this one slightly seems better, cuz I I
could withhold judgment on something
like that. If I was like 50/50, I would
say I I don't believe that he existed. I
don't believe he didn't exist. I'm I'm
undecided on the matter. So to say I
believe something kind of has to be
like, you know, 80% or something like
that. Uh seems like 80% probability, 90%
or something like that. And I'll say,
"Okay, I believe that." So I believe I
believe that Muhammad existed and that I
would say I have a high level of
confidence in that. Um so for me to sort
of join their side, they would have to
show me that they have a significantly
better explanation. If they just showed
they have like an equally plausible
explanation for his non-existence, then
I would say, "Okay, well I'm then I'm
undecided. I don't know. I'm agnostic on
the issue." Uh, so for me to actually
say no, Muhammad didn't exist, they'd
have to show they have a way better case
that he didn't exist than that he did.
The problem is anytime they give the
arguments and then the arguments will
circulate for a while and as soon as we
actually sit down and examine the
argument, it turns out to be based on
either a lot of speculation or a lot of
uh a lot of questionable argumentation
or just flatout nonsense, which is like
the uh that Jesus was known as Mahmad.
And so that's that was complete
nonsense. It was completely made up. And
I still have them telling me it every
day. I still have the nomos telling me
every single day. But you haven't
refuted the mukmut. What are you talking
about? Even Jay backed off backed off
that when it was refuted to him. Um so
anyway, yeah, that that that would be
>> need a better need a better explanation
that isn't based on a bunch of madeup
stuff as soon as we examine it.
>> Right. So now now here's now now here
let me give you ultimately what I'm
trying to get at too is that there is no
kind I'm I'm trying to let my mind go
wild and see what kind of evidence that
could possibly come up with even though
I know they don't have it but let's say
this and this is just to show you how
this sort of argumentation there's
always a response to it. So, what if we
found um we found a written in Arabic uh
parchment or book from the 8th century
and it's by some Arab king who flat out
says, "We created in our court a man
named Muhammad and we gave him these
characteristics and we did all this to
validate ourselves." Now, I'm sure the
Mo Nomos would have a field day and
cases closed, but it still wouldn't be
closed because guess what? The Nomo's
entire premise is built on conspiracy
theories. Everyone's lying. Everyone's
hiding. Everyone's misrepresenting. So,
how do we know that isn't the lie? You
see what I'm saying? It can never be
concrete proof. That's why for me, this
entire thing is just sort of like at
best an academic exercise. Uh especially
when it's done among non-Muslims. It's
just an academic exercise as I tried to
explain. So anyway, just to finalize how
I got into the debate thing and because
it's really relevant to what we're going
to talk about is uh so I made those
videos saying basically what I'm saying
right now and um this is why I don't
believe this is why I do believe
Muhammad exists and I gave all my
reasons and one of the most important
reasons you know for for whoever didn't
watch the debate this is really what it
comes down to which is that historians
what they do to determine the historical
veracity of a character which happened
to Jesus by the way is that what they do
is they actually first of all discount
the writings by their followers. Okay?
Because they say they're biased. So for
all the people who were skeptical about
Jesus, they didn't want to look at Paul.
They didn't want to look at the go the
Gospels or the New Testament because
they're biased. They believe in
miracles. Who's going to believe these
guys? So we we start looking for Roman
writers who mention Jesus, right? And
then they they find them, right? And so
the same thing happened with Muhammad.
So they said, "Well, we're not going to
look at the standard Islamic narrative.
We want to find what others said." And
lo and behold, there's 15 uh
contemporary sources of non these are
not Muslims. So this isn't part of a
conspiracy. They're not late. So you
can't say, "Oh, this is hundreds of
years after Muhammad. You can't trust
it." Which is itself another weak
argument because almost everything we
have about historical characters from
the seventh century and before is
hundreds of years after their existence.
And we don't say they don't exist. Okay.
But so we had and and I quoted some of
them um you know two years after
Muhammad's uh life you have someone
talking about an Arabian prophet who
comes with swords and chariots and
promises paradise to his followers. I
mean that's a description of Muhammad to
a tea. We have another Armenian bishop
like 20 or 30 years later who calls him
by name Muhammad and then says he came
he he presents himself as a prophet in
the line of the Old Testament and he
banned them from drinking alcohol.
That's Muhammad. Okay. And then you know
to show you the the you mentioned the
Mahmud argument and to show you how
really bad this is. I don't know what
argument you're referring to that Jay
backed off but the first thing that
struck me as an Arabic speaker when I
heard Mouhammad means the praised one
and therefore it doesn't mean Muhammad
the person that's a later kind of
attribution but it what he doesn't seem
to understand is every single Arabic
name means something means
somethingatory honorific
like praised one. Ahmed means the same
thing. Karim is the generous one. Azim
the mighty one. Um, you know, any name
that you can think of, Rasheed, you
know, the swift one, they all mean
something. And if you want to twist it,
you can probably say they're appalations
for Jesus Christ if you want. And then
the other flip side of this argument,
because it seems like Jay vacasillates
on Muhammad's name. On the one hand, he
claims this, you know, the Muhammad is
the praise one to Jesus. But when you
look at the writings in the that I'm
referring to, the contemporary
non-Muslim writings in Greek, the what
Jay and so many others are apparently
getting tripped over is how the they how
the Greeks transliterate Muhammad's
name. Okay? And as you know,
transliterate means you're trying to
approximate and capture the sounds of a
foreign language with your own alphabet.
Okay? And as it happens in Greek, there
is no H letter. So you cannot write
Muhammad. Okay? So how would you write
it? you would write mamett and that's
exactly what they write and but others
don't write that others put a a kai
because they're trying to approximate
the h sound. So anyway for for Jay and
others this is proof that's not the same
guy because that's not how you spell
Muhammad. And yet in this right now
today how many ways have you seen in
English Muhammad spelled? There's
countless ways at least half half a
dozen that are pretty regular. So you
got Muhammad with a U, Muhammad with a
O. Um, and and if you and Muhammad and
and at the end it's an A or the at the
end it's it's an E before the D. And
then if you go back a century, it was it
was very common to see Muhammad with a T
on the end. Yeah. And different
spellings of that. Yeah. So
>> and one of Jay's big arguments is, oh,
because sometimes in the Greek they put
a T, not a D. Well, so my point, this is
a transliteration. This is some guy
writing in Greek in the seventh century
trying to sound out this funny name and
spelling it with Greek letters. This is
absolutely nothing to get tripped up on.
And so Jay always acts like, "Oh, and
the translators, they change it to
Muhammad." Well, of course they do that.
That's I'm a translator. That's exactly
what you would do because, you know,
that's what they're saying. I'm not
going to get caught up on the
transliteration. We all know what
they're talking about. So anyway, I just
wanted to mention that because I think
so those are the key points. And then
anyway, um soon thereafter, Jay started
challenging me to a debate. Okay? And at
first he misrepresented everything I
said. that he made a video um just
putting all kinds of words in my mouth
that I do that day.
>> Yeah. All sorts of positions I never
said and then um and then I called him
out on it and then he's like, "No, let's
have a debate. Let's have a debate." So
So what is what does he want to debate
me with? Well, I only made those two
videos and my two videos were about
proving that Muhammad existed through
the early non-Muslim sources and the
name thing, right? But then when we had
the debate all of a sudden and I brought
all those points up, he started saying,
"Oh, that's not what I thought we were
going to talk about." Okay. Um, so
anyway, that's how I've been dragged
into this and I actually entered it in
good faith because um, a lot of people
were getting upset with what I'm saying
and I wanted to clarify and say, "Look,
this is why I don't believe it." And
there's so many other sort of important
philosophical points I've been trying to
make to a lot of these nomos. Um, you
know, primarily that it really doesn't
matter. It it's this argument of Nommo
only has importance and validity when
it's when it's applied to Muslims
because then it's a pmic and yes
theoretically it could make a Muslim
doubt and leave Islam. You and I I think
we both agree it's very weak but that is
what it's designed for. It's a pmic.
Okay. But that's not what I'm seeing and
I don't think that's what you're seeing.
What we're seeing is it's being target.
It's being weaponized against other
non-Muslims and Christians. Yeah. and
and causing and in this case and what do
we gain and it's like if you if I were
to convert what what is it like five
billion non-Muslims in the world if
every one of them became a no mower what
happens Islam's going to die nothing
will change nothing changes in our mind
think about it I believe you and I
believe Muhammad existed but he was a
false prophet what does that mean it
means Muslims are misguided by a lie Jay
believes Muhammad never existed what
does that mean it means Muslims are
misguided by a lie one is a fake prophet
one is a make believe prophet nothing
really changes in our minds and yet and
yet it's being pushed on us non-Muslims
like it's so important and we have to
it's a cardinal faith and we have to
accept it you know anyway I've rambled
on so I'll let you uh take it over
>> yeah I just wanted to um well two things
I just wanted everyone to know um we
have a lot of Zoot fans um in the chat
uh this has become a I don't know if
you've seen it as much as I have but uh
everyone's uh everyone's bringing up
Zoot ever everywhere I am the Zoot man.
I I'm I popularized the Zoot.
>> That's what I That's what I wanted to
point out. See, I'd heard it I'd heard
it for years, but it was always from the
uh basically the Arab the Arabic
channels. Um and I'd hear people who
follow them and they're like, "Hey, do
you know this?" and so on. And anyway,
uh I just I'll I'll hear something for
years and I I'm always waiting like,
"What's the right time? What's the right
time?" when it gets to the right time,
somehow I'll just know it's the right
time and then I'll I'll I'll I'll jump
on an issue and start start spreading it
around. Um, and it was your video, your
video. You came out with the Zoot video,
and I was like, "Oh, now's a here's a
clear one. It's available in English.
All right, here's the right time." So,
uh, so then I I took clips of that, made
a video out of it. And uh now now Alz is
everywhere.
>> And the irony the irony is I made that
video specifically in response to the
Nomos. Um because the whole point was to
show because their their argument when
when we say you know the embarrassing uh
hadith like what's the logic? Why why
would Muhammad's life if he's a madeup
you know supposedly higgraphical prophet
who people should be looking up to why
is his entire biography full of
embarrassing shameful things? Um, and
the Nommo response is so it's so weak
and it's just it does it
>> it's insulting to one's intelligence.
It's basically um you and I are
anacronizing and we don't understand
that everything that we think is
embarrassing was just so cool to the
seventh century Arabs and it's kind of
like no it actually a lot of the stuff
that we find embarrassing was even worse
for them. Okay. Include uh so for
example, how do you think a 7th century
Arabs ultra uber patriarchical all about
tribal honor and manhood uh think it's
cool that their prophet goes out in a
desert and gets ridden by a bunch of
tall naked zoot all night long? You
think that's a cool thing for them? Even
Kafir pointed out this is a very odd and
strange hadith. It was embarrassing from
day one. Okay. And there's a lot of that
sort of thing. So when they argue that,
oh no, we just don't get it. that oh
that that was all so cool back then that
that is such a weak argument that's
really kind of insulting to one's
intelligence.
>> Yeah, we're going to see uh we're going
to see a clip of um Jay and Robert
responding and and and to be fair they
are correct in that um beliefs today do
not necessarily and very frequently
don't match match beliefs 14 centuries
ago. Yeah. So things that are
embarrassing to us aren't necessarily
embarrassing to but there are things
that we know were embarrassing even back
then. And and I want to say a lot of it
is a lot of the uh speculations that
come up are uh well maybe maybe there
was a reason that this was acceptable.
We just don't know. Uh and that and
that's always possible. Like guess what
it's because you're talking about
historic history being probabilistic.
It's possible that there was some reason
this was thought of as a as a really
cool thing to do and we just don't know
it. But you'd have to think okay what
what are the odds of that? Seems pretty
slim. But guess what? So if you had to
do that for one thing that would be that
would be one issue. But when you need to
do that for like 10,000 different
stories in the Muslim sources and say
maybe it was because of this, maybe this
ruler wanted it because of this, maybe
they thought seaman all over his clothes
was cool because of this, maybe they
thought the satanic verses were awesome
because of this.
>> Now, you have to to to get the
probability of your basically giant
conspiracy here.
>> You need to multiply all those. And so
if it's like 1% time half a percent time
10% time 2% and stuff you get you get
this massively improbable hypothesis and
that's uh that's what we're
>> and why complicate it so much why not
just be able to read between the lines
and say these were people who were
slavishly just writing down and
memorizing anything they could and you
know guess what a lot of as you would
expect a lot of warts came through
because this man was a pretty fallible
human being and there it is on open
display and if anything it's great proof
for his existence.
>> Yeah. Yeah. And uh there is an element
of uh AAM's razor here like hey what's
the what's the simplest explanation is
that there's a guy who did all this
messed up stuff or a lot of it and his
followers recorded some of it versus oh
maybe there was a ruler that we don't
know about who thought uh getting banged
out in the desert was really cool and
maybe there's this other guy who thought
it was really cool being covered in
seaman and maybe and maybe and maybe and
all of a sudden now you've got like
5,000 hypothetical dudes all teaching
this weird creepy stuff and you don't
know that any of these guys exist and
you're just well maybe maybe okay guys
you can do that with anyone. You can do
that with anyone.
>> Exactly.
>> Yeah.
>> Exactly. That's that's what they don't
get. They what they do is they jettison
the most approved and trusted standards
of historical criteria, primary sources,
and they just poo poo them away. Oh
yeah, because they get in the way of our
agenda. All these seventh century, you
know, um John of Damascus, give me a
break. this guy living, you know, just
40, 50, 60 years after Muhammad, talking
about Muhammad, writing about Muhammad.
Yeah. Mentioning Quran suras, but hey,
he didn't get it all right. Therefore,
he's he was I mean, the the arguments
they make are really asinine. What do
you of course he didn't get it right?
The guy who says he was perfect. The
guy's working in horrible conditions. He
doesn't have the internet to find out
what the Quran says online. um you
expect mistakes in the writings, but
everything he writes and then and Abu
and um Theodor Abuakura writes Muhammad
the same way uh John of Damascus does in
Greek and then in Arabic he writes it
the exact way Muhammad. It's like it's
so to me to argue against this is now
you're you now you've left the realm of
just objective thinking and you just you
have an agenda and you need to take
these out and then as we're pointing out
then they do the exact opposite. Then
they find the most extreme hypothesis
and they if it works for them then they
treat it like this is the unassalable
concrete omnisient proof that knows
everything and cannot be doubted. I mean
their methodology is really really
sloppy and by historical standards kind
of a joke to be honest with you. And it
is and and part of the issue is that Jay
will take something that's um that's
complete speculation or just complete
fabrication or something like that. But
he'll say it with the same confidence as
he's saying something that is that is
like that is really strong evidence and
so on. He has the same level of
confidence no matter what he's saying.
But you you were you were uh asking
about the uh the Mahmad issue. This is
kind of
>> I I wasn't I wasn't uh I wasn't involved
in this discussion. Uh Mary and Thaddius
came out with uh Mary came out with a
coins video, a response to J. Smith. And
I was interested because I've never I
never looked uh looked into it too much.
So I wanted to to go through that and
stuff. But before we actually got to
that, um I've always held the position,
hey, if you guys want to make your
argument that Muhammad didn't exist,
awesome. Cuz if you convince someone
with that, cool. Um I'll argue what I
think, you argue that, and we'll see.
We'll see how things we'll see how
things work out.
>> They're not arguing against Muslims.
They're arguing against us. That's what
I mean. And as as you pointed, they're
coming they're coming at us. They're
demanding this cultlike allegiance.
Everyone has to be on the same page or
you're evil. Or you're evil and you must
have some ulterior motive. Um but so
anyway, but even like Jay's been saying,
he said a long time ago that the only
reason I'm not on board with the uh with
the uh the Nommo crowd is because
there's too much money in it for me if
I'm right. And Muhammad is this really
really bad dude. So he was saying that
years ago. And so I never said one word.
guys, go ahead, find go ahead and find
me saying anything about it. Never said
it. Never said anything in response. If
you want to argue like that, if you want
to argue like that, fine. Uh, just go
ahead. But it's more recently when other
people started responding. Giant DOC and
Mary and Thaddius started responding to
some of his claims that they like some
of it's like extremely problematic, just
flat out made up. And then it was
they're just responding because they're
jealous of his him and they're just
responding because of this or that. And
it was the same exact thing, but now it
was about now it wasn't about me. say it
about me all day all day long. Now it
was about now it was about my friends
and he's just they're what's crazy is
they were completely right and he
eventually had to back off the argument
and say he's going to stop using it and
so on but they were correct but the PE
so people are correcting him on bad
arguments or on mistakes and he's he's
still responding as if they're just in
it for something else when eventually
he's agreeing with them on some of the
issues and so this is just really weird
stuff but uh uh go ahead and say what
you wanted to say and then we'll watch
the little clip so you can see what
we're talking about.
Well, I was just thinking of all the
accusations that they're making against
us. And one of them that I I I heard and
I've seen and I wanted to just, you
know, dispel very quickly is the one
that like people like you and I are
worried that if Muhammad is taken away,
we're going to lose our bread and butter
because our job is to attack Muhammad.
Okay? And and here here's now the other
part of this cult, the egoism, the
egotistical attitude because we believe
Muhammad doesn't exist.
erggo two billion Muslims also believe
it. The fact is
>> their confidence is based on us. Their
confidence is based on us. And if we
switch then then all the confidence of
Muslims in the existence of Muhammad
would collapse and Islam would collapse.
And we're like no don't let Islam
collapse.
>> Don't let that happen.
>> What are we going to do with our lives?
What would we ever find to do?
>> And and they don't seem to understand
that. Uh meanwhile two billion Muslims
believe Muhammad existed. So I think uh
you know we have good job security if
that's the issue because what you guys
are saying is totally ineffective. So
we're not even bringing it up because
we're afraid Muslims are going to leave
Islam and we don't have something to do.
They're there. You are ineffective. And
it just again shows you how they're not
even thinking clearly when they make
these kind of silly accusations and
arguments.
>> Yeah. And um I I pointed out in a recent
live stream when this came up because uh
you're getting blasted with this uh I'm
getting blasted with the same
accusation. Not the way Muhammad is
getting blasted by Alz, but everyone
knows what we're talking about. Um, but
yeah, people are and I I just I
responded like even the Dawa guys
stopped responding with this years ago
and it's just because I mean we've been
getting threatened with brutal murder
for all these years. I I had to I had to
point out that um I mean
when when my friend Nabil and I when we
decided we're going to go after Islam,
we actually concluded that we were
probably signing our death certificates
because there weren't a lot of people
doing it back then. And if there's only
a couple people doing it, it is and
we're going around actually speaking on
it and stuff pretty e and we're actually
like going to the Dearborn Arab festival
and stuff like this and people are
saying if we show up they're going to
kill us. If we show up here they're
going to kill us. If we show up there
they're going to kill us. Uh well, you
know, you obviously think most of these
people are just running their mouths,
but there probably a couple serious
people in there and we wouldn't be
exactly hard to kill if we're going
around speaking and so on. So we
actually thought when we were deciding
to do this that we were dead and we were
we're willing we're willing to do it.
Nibil when he was about to propose
marriage to his wife had to say you you
know there's a really good chance I'm
going to be killed. Um I had to when I
mean no it was actually my wife but when
our kids turned four and six we're
getting all sorts of death threats and
I'd be traveling sometimes and she had
to actually sit my four-year-old and my
six-year-old sons down and say guys if
someone ever comes through the door and
you hear a big commotion and someone is
hurting me and you hear me screaming I
do not want you to come help me. I want
you to run and hide. And even if uh even
if you hear me screaming, do not come
and help me. I want you to hide and just
know that I'm more worried about you
guys than I am about myself. And so she
had to actually have this discussion
with my kids and so on. Uh but e like
again even the da guys because when we
started this, oh you guys are just
criticizing Islam because of all the
money you'll make. Not like oh it like
destroys like destroys your life in a
lot of ways. Everyone attacked you.
Everyone attacked you back then. Uh
because Muslims would attack you and
they'd say oh you're you're an evil
person. and we're going to kill you and
we're going to do this to your wife and
we're going to do this to your mom.
We're going to do this to your kids and
stuff. Um, atheists would attack you.
They'd say, "Um, but you're religious,
too. How can you how can you uh complain
about another religion when your
religion is just as dumb hypocrite?" And
they'd be blasting you. But back then,
Christians would attack you as well.
They'd say, "It's not loving to be
attacking Muhammad and the Quran. Uh,
you're going to hurt their feelings and
so on. So, shame on you. You just got
blasted from every direction." Uh but
but back then the DA guys were saying
yes, they're just doing this because
there's so many benefits to it all. Um
so much money involved, but even they
gave that up over over many years
because it was just obvious if a guy
says he's going to kill me in Time
Square and I show up to Time Square with
the camera rolling, giving him the
opportunity, just becomes obvious to
people, you must really believe what
you're doing because you're repeatedly
ready to lay down your life for this
stuff. And it's the same thing I would
say about Jay Smith. Someone said the
reason Jay Smith's doing all this is for
money or something. I would say that guy
was on the ladder at Speaker's Corner
surrounded by Muslims for decades.
There's no way he's doing it for for
some ulterior motive. He's putting his
life on the line regularly over and over
again. So, it wouldn't even make sense.
So, anyway, the DA guys even gave that
up. Now, the only place I hear this from
is the nomos. They're the ones I hear it
from all the time. You guys are just
doing this. the only reason you're
defending Muhammad is because you're
getting paid by you're getting paid by
Saudi Arabia or Qatar or something like
this. You're getting paid by Israel.
You're there's just too much money
involved for you. And this again, this
is
>> how's it defending Muhammad to say he
exists, but he was a despicable human
being. They they don't seem to get that.
You know, uh 14 centuries of Christians
who who stuck their neck out to the
sword and were martyed all believed
Muhammad existed, but they believed he
was a false prophet. I don't get this
inongruity where, you know, if you
believe in this man's existence, you are
now somehow and I think we're going to
see, you know, people making those exact
comments. Uh just because you believe he
existed, you're on his side. You're a
helper of Islam. I mean it. And the
thing is, you know, I like you for 20
years I've had my enemies and they would
be Muslims and leftists. At this point,
nobody is worse than the Nomos. They are
the most vocal, the most hostile, the
most acrimonious in their attacks. And
it's just kind of like and again it's
because they're a cult that their mind
is cultic and uh when we say what we say
which is Muhammad existed it just is
such a challenge to their faith that we
become these horrible you know atheists
and Satanists and definitely
non-Christians.
>> Yeah. And and that's all tied to it. You
know what it reminds me of? Reminds me
of uh like so uh Muhammad when he's in
Mecca he's telling the Meccans he's
surrounded by polytheists but he's
telling them yeah I'm in the books of
the Jews and Christians and when they
see me they'll confirm me because they
know they know me man they'll know me as
soon as I see me because I'm in their
scriptures and they know they've got my
complete description in their scriptures
and so when I run into some Jews or
Christians you guys are going to see
these guys be like this is the prophet
we've all been waiting for. Well he
tells his followers that for years and
then they actually go to Medina and the
Jews are like what are you kidding me?
You think you're in our scriptures?
Well, you're a joke, dude. And what
becomes the response then? Oh, they know
I'm in their scriptures, but they're
lying, right? So,
people wonder, you know, why do you have
like uh the end will not come until the
Muslims fight the Jews and the Jews are
hiding behind rocks and trees and the
rocks and trees are saying, "Hey,
there's a Muslim. There's a Jew coming.
There's a Jew behind me. Come kill him."
Why do they why are they calling for
complete extermination of the Jews?
Because it's not a difference of
opinion. It's not uh they're not they
don't sincerely reject Muhammad. They
know he's a true prophet and they're
against him anyway, which means they're
against God. They're against the truth.
They're on the side of complete evil and
they're trying to cover up the truth and
it's well these guys are just pure evil.
They have to die. Well, it's a there's a
parallel with us. If you just say, "Hey,
we're looking at the same evidence, but
you know, people are different. People
are different. Uh some some people have
a have a lot of confidence in the
principle of embarrassment. Other people
not so much." Well, guess what? You're
going to come to different conclusions.
based on the evidence based on these
kinds of things. We're all individuals.
We have different ways of thinking. Uh
we have different different amounts and
kinds of evidence in front of us. And so
we're going to come to different
conclusions. Instead of that, it's oh,
these guys know that Muhammad didn't
exist, but they're covering it up and
they're working for Saudi Arabia and
they're working for Israel and they're
trying to cover up the truth and they're
trying to keep Muslims in Islam instead
of getting them all out of Islam. And so
what? We're on the side of evil. We're
sick evil. We're sick evil people
serving the forces of Satan. by saying
that Muhammad exists and what I I say
Muhammad existed and he's the most
obvious pro false prophet in history but
um that's what they're paying us to say
>> tenant of their faith and by the way um
you know before we leave the mom praised
one topic and just to show you you know
the sort the how I register
>> we're we're about to watch a clip on
that but go ahead
>> how I register the arguments that Jay
Smith makes and to me they sound like
the Muslim pmics so when I hear Jay
Smith saying Muhammad This is really a a
title and a name of Jesus Christ. You
know what that reminds me of? It reminds
me of Muslims saying, "Oh, Muhammad is
prophesied in the New Testament. He's
the pariclete." You've heard that. I
mean, how absurd is that? And that's
exactly how absurd it is to tell a
Muslim, "Oh, Muhammad means Jesus."
Okay. It's just it's the same silly kind
of argumentations that they're borrowing
from each other.
>> Yeah. So, uh, this was a this clip was
actually a preview of, um, a response
when we had giant doc because giant doc
and here here's what's amazing. When,
uh, Jay responds to people, it's, "Oh,
um, they're just doing it because
they're jealous because I'm finally
getting attention and they have to shut
this down because their careers depend
on attacking.
>> Everyone's trying to shut him down."
That's his line.
>> Yeah. Everyone's trying to Everyone's
trying to shut him down and stop him and
so on. Um, and they're just jealous
because he's uh, because it's catching
on and so on. Um, I I've I've heard I've
been involved behind the scenes when
people are going, "Should we respond to
that? We don't want to cause division,
man, and we don't want to we don't want
to hurt Jay's reputation, but we we
don't know what to do. He's telling
people this horrible information, and
it's going to blow up in their faces.
They're going to go out and share this,
and it might even catch on, and you
might end up with millions of Christians
sharing the same argument when all it
takes is a one- minute search to find
out it's completely wrong." And this is
this is going to be they're they're
saying this is going to be like our
holes in the narrative when uh you know
the the argument from perfect
preservation of the Quran came crashing
to the ground. Why? Because it was based
on a lie. Well, guess what? If you if
you convince a bunch of people to use
something as evidence and it's very easy
to refute, it's a matter of time before
enough people pay attention, they just
crush it. And do we want do we want that
to happen? Do we do we want that to
happen to tons of Christians or do we
actually want to try and like like show
that it's wrong right now? But so that's
what's going on behind the scenes is we
don't want to cause division. We don't
want to we don't want to uh we don't
want to discredit Jay, but he what he's
saying is factually false right here.
What do we do? And it's like a struggle
for them to decide, do we actually call
this out? Well, anyway, Giant DOC
decided to call it out. So, and they're
very gentle. They're like, "Hey, Jay's
done great work. Jay's done awesome
stuff, but he's just wrong in this. He's
getting some bad information from uh
some people." And um uh Jay's response
was interesting. But anyway, that's the
background of this clip. And then to
preview our discussion after Jay
responded, uh, they put together this
little clip just to show what was kind
of what was kind of coming up. But here
here it is.
In some ways, this is what we call peer
review. I'm not I'm not saying that that
that uh Kai and daughter of Christ are
peers and that they have they're they're
at the same level that we have because
we've been working on this for many many
years.
>> Previously on our channel,
>> what does Mmud mean in Arabic? It is not
a name. It is a title. It means the
praised one, the blessed one, the
anointed one, or even the Messiah.
>> Okay, guys.
>> No, it doesn't. No, it doesn't. No, it
doesn't. No, it doesn't.
>> It does not. There's no no one in the
world, no one is going to tell you that
it means the Messiah or the anointed one
or even the blessed one.
So to clarify, Mmed doesn't mean blessed
one or 9 to one. I I did try to make
that clear to Jay that oligant linked by
a
>> So this is Mel's response. So Mel is the
source of a lot of information that Jay
just goes out and and would would kind
of regurgitate and uh um and here Mel in
response to Giant Doc kind of calling
out Jay for saying that this is what
Mahmad means. Um Mel just oh no no no no
of no it's not what I meant and was no
one's even talking about you Mel they're
talking about Jay but then uh Mel takes
it as a personal attack against him even
though no literally no one's talking
about him but uh here's here's him uh uh
responding
>> what does Mhm mean in Arabic it means
the praised one blessed one just said no
no anointed one St. Abro's writing in
Syriak talks about this Muhammmed from
Song of Smud 560 and he says this is a
title for Jesus Christ the anointed one
the
>> no he doesn't
>> Messiah that's what the anointed one is
from that time on from the 4th century
AD it was this Makma was employed by
many of the church fathers here's
>> it was employed by zero church fathers
Jay you said many
>> guess what no one on that list uses
Makmad as a title for Jesus no one
that's kind the point he's saying,
"Look, all these people." And guess
what? The the audience, oh my goodness,
so much evidence. Wow, it's all right
there. Notice he's not giving you a
quote from anyone showing that anyone
uses this. He's just saying, "All these
people say it and people walk away. Wow,
this is good information." And then they
come use it on me. And then that's
that's kind of the point. It's Jay is
now Jay was spreading this to tons of
people. Uh it's completely false. It's
not there. People are coming at me with
this every single day. They're coming at
Giant Doc. They're coming to everyone.
Oh, Makma, that was just a name. That
was a name for that was that was the
name for Jesus. That's where all this
comes from. And then you look up the
sources doesn't say it anywhere. And
then they have to backtrack on it. So
check this out. So the arguments are no.
>> This is Mel's response to it being
pointed out that no one used this
father's ever used Mak as a prophetic
title or name. And I I would argue this
is a straw man argument. That isn't what
we claimed.
>> This Mbed was employed by many of the
church fathers. Here are some examples.
Oregon. So, it's not a name. It's not a
name, folk. It's a title.
>> I'm quite happy to back away from that
and say, "No, I shouldn't shouldn't have
said title. I should have probably just
used the word um adjective or noun or
term or something."
>> Not even used as
>> like that. And
>> watch what he says here though, guys.
Listen to this.
>> Subsequently employed by St. Ambrose in
the 4th century as a title for Jesus
Christ. The Jews also referred to it in
their reference. And what was
interesting by the seventh century the
Jews started using that title for their
exalcarks.
>> No they didn't.
>> Exelarks were those who were in charge
of the seminary in what is today
Baghdad. Arabic. So they have all been
speaking Arabic and they had always put
Mhm before their name. M
>> guys did
>> put Mhm before their name. Mhm. Ben
Huziel. Mhmmed ben David.
>> There's no Mhm. Ben Oel. There's no M
bided. What else?
>> Mhm. Ben everyone. They have
>> Mhmed ben. Everyone guys, there's no
Mmed ben anything in any Jewish source
relating to what he's talking about.
>> Wow.
>> You mentioned Jews in Baghdad using MMED
as a title of endearment, specifically
MCMed bin Uziel and Mmed bin Joseph.
I've checked digitized Hebrew libraries
in Hebrew and have not found any matches
for those exact phrases. There are no
rabbitic usages of the word makmed in
the way you described. So, my short
answer is I haven't ever claimed that we
had evidence for that.
>> I I've never claimed that we had
evidence for that.
Um Jay states it as fact and when you're
when challenged on it, it's I've never
claimed that there's any evidence for
that.
>> I think what they're referring to and
this is something that I have said in
the past, you have said in the past
about a year or two, two years ago, we
did say and I remember even uh
>> you hear this. So Jay knows that he's on
record saying this and so he says, "Ah,
yeah, in the past one to two years ago,
but I we've since backed off this when
they show they're actually responding to
his video from last month." It was his
video last month that he was saying this
in. He's saying, "Oh, I backed off."
Yeah, we realized there was no evidence
for that. So we backed off it one to two
years ago. This is this a quick
question.
>> This is called gas this is called
gaslighting. By the way, you just said
that last month. No, I didn't. That was
years ago. No, it was last month. That
was years ago. Anyway, what's that? So
my question now is, you know, I didn't
even know all this about what he was
saying. Um, and seeing that it's
completely made up, okay? Is he what is
what is going on? Is he just a liar or
does he or is he just the sloppiest
researcher? I mean, it has to be one or
the other. We can't just let it pass
like that. What are we dealing with
here? If someone if he's making these
powerful supposedly arguments that are
based that he just pulls out of thin air
and then says, "Oh, they're based on
this document and this this and that."
and then we find out they don't even
exist. What's going on? Is he literally
just creating things out of thin air or
is his research methodology just that
pathetic? It has to be one or the other.
>> Yeah, that uh we backed off that one to
two years ago. That has to be gaslight
because that's him saying it. That's not
That's him saying it in this in this
response video. Oh, yeah. Yeah. We we
said that in the past, but we backed off
to that, you know, a year or two ago.
And it's it's literally from his video,
you know, in July. Um there that seems
like that seems like gaslighting. Uh you
know uh you want to think you want to
try and think the best. As far as him
using this argument, it seems like
people were just feeding him bad
information and he was just he's just
going with whatever like people here's a
great
>> needs to verify it himself.
>> That's what I mean. of all I so the
everyone who's watching the most
charitable the most charitable
interpretation here is Jay is extremely
sloppy and basically anyone who hands
him an argument against the existence of
Muhammad he'll run with it even if
there's nothing and the problem is
>> he will state it with complete 100%
certainty that this is known factual
information that's and then give it to
the audience and then the audience runs
out yeah it's everyone knows this is
true
>> and it's not it's completely made up so
notice if if you have someone who's
really really sloppy and they'll believe
anything someone by the way it reminds
me of Muhammad being called the ear. Um,
but if you have people being fed
information and they don't vet it and
they go out and say it to their to their
audience
>> and you know that you need to look up
everything that person says because if
it if if a person will say 2 plus 2
equals four with the same confidence
that they say Mahmud was used as a title
by all these church fathers for Jesus
and he'll say that with the exact same
confidence level then their confidence
tells you nothing about whether their
information is is accurate or not. You
need to look into the stuff for
yourself.
Like you said, the most charitable
interpretation on based on what we just
evaluated is that he is just a sloppy
researcher.
>> Yeah, that's the charitable one. All
right, there's uh there's a little bit
left.
>> Putting we did a video together where we
thought that there were there were five
exelarks uh who had Mahmud before their
name and that these all five were in the
seventh century. And we now no longer
are saying that because that was
something that we had assumed back then.
But then now that we've looked at the
sources more carefully, we're now
pulling back on that. Uh the reference
to Mhhammed Ben Husel or Nehemiah Ben
Husel or Mahm Ben David, we're now we
don't see any sources for that. We don't
see any reference for that. We're now
pulling back on that
>> if it is true.
>> Imagine pulling back um after you
realize there's no evidence for what
you're saying and not like not saying it
to begin with because there's no
evidence for it and it would just be
made up nonsense. um once yes
>> any reference for that we're now pulling
back on that
>> if it is true that they backtracked on
that claim how is it that it was put out
only a month ago to 1.3 million people
>> put Mm before their name Mhmiel
Mahmed bin David
I'm not saying that that that uh Kai and
daughter of Christ are peers and that
they have they're they're at the same
level that we have because we've been
working on this for many many years.
>> Okay. You've been working on it many
many years and they instantly I think
Jai said it took them like a minute to
look this stuff up.
Yeah. So, um yeah, they're not they're
not peers, but um anyway, they the
research that you've been doing for
years and discovered all this stuff and
have been telling to uh millions of
people was completely wrong as soon as
someone looked it up.
>> Um that should tell you something. So,
as far as the uh uh Mahmad and Song of
Solomon, what Jay was talking about
right there is backing off the claim
that um the Jews use this as a title,
Mahmud bin Uzil and so on. Uh the the
other part that once we looked into this
was um uh giant DOC of course uh but
then we we looked into it in in a live
stream but it was that Mahmad. So the so
the claim here is in Song of Solomon in
Song of Solomon 5:16 there's a word used
for lovely. She's calling the beloved
lovely and uses the word Mahmadim which
is the plural of Mahmad. Muslims use
this as an argument that Muhammad's in
the Bible. Terrible terrible argument.
Um but here's
>> worse than Jay's right.
>> Yeah I I agree. Um but anyway, so the
argument is well as far as Jay was
saying was all these church fathers are
using Mahmad as this title for Jesus and
uh it just became super common and
that's the theory about how you ended up
with references to Makmad back then and
that's the origin of Muhammad, right?
That's the real origin of Muhammad. Um
and so all these church fathers are
talking about it just became a standard
title for Jesus. Problem is not one of
them ever said it anywhere. it it does
it doesn't exist. And when you asked uh
when when uh it's it was put to Mel to
defend this, the claim is actually well
there were church fathers who said that
Song of Solomon is is is uh figurative.
It's allegorical. It's it's about Jesus
love for the church. Okay, that part is
true. There were church fathers who
interpreted Song of Solomon
allegorically as not between Solomon and
his bride, but between Jesus and the
church. Um but everything beyond that is
just completely made up. that therefore
they went to this one verse 5:16 and
then they instead of reading it in Greek
and Hebrew which is what church fathers
would have been reading it in they
instead said we need to go to the Hebrew
here and then they see that the Hebrew
word is makmadim and then they went with
makmud and they said we'll make a title
out of this and then it spreads all over
the place even though we have no record
of this ever happening and then this
becomes so prominent that people
eventually think that it's a different
figure a guy named Muhammad and it's
like it's all made up apart from there
were church fathers who thought song of
Solomon is about Jesus, everything else
is made up. And but and yet, Raymond,
when we reject that powerful argument,
we're evil and we're working for wealthy
Arabs.
>> And and just, you know, again, to show
you the violence that he does to
history, you know, this MMED. Okay. So,
as you pointed out, because now Mahmed
means a praise one, all these guys are
now named Mahmed. So the guys that I was
referring to in the seventh century that
you know Greek sources refer to and call
ma Muhammad or Muhammad or whatever
these I've heard Jay say were actually
Christians. So the ones that are
actually recorded as coming and killing
Christians in Syria and in Jerusalem by
Thomas the Presbyter etc. Jay has said
that was a Christian guy who was being
called the praised one in honor of
Jesus. So look at the sort of violence
that and how he just completely distorts
history from from what it was which is
it's Muhammad okay and here he is
engaged in violence killing Christians
and now we have a long continuum of the
same behavior till today makes perfect
sense but in order to Jay to prove his
point no that was a Christian guy coming
and killing Christians and now
everything that's been happening since
is all just nobody understands how it
came about. It's just all conspiracy,
conspiracy, conspiracy. Everything is a
lie except J. Smith's highly conjectural
ideas that are just so ephemeral and
tenuous. That is always what we have to
believe. And if we go against that,
we're sinners. I mean, I don't know.
>> Yeah. And uh it's a situation where
going back to what I was saying earlier,
like what would it take for me to sway
to what would it take to sway me in the
uh in the nommo direction? Um and I said
you got to come up with a better
explanation for for the evidence. Um, I
acknowledge there are all sorts of
problems with the Muslim sources on how
late a lot of them are and how much they
were fabricating uh and inventing
stories and so on. I I can recognize all
of that. For me to say non-existent, I
would have to you would have to have a
better explanation for all this came up
came up. But when they offer an
explanation for how you get to Muhammad,
it's all made up nonsense. It's all just
completely made up. And it's like, how
is that going to be a better explanation
when it's all as soon as we examine it,
it's made up?
>> And that's the concrete one. And another
argument um you know that I made that
again just to show you how
unsatisfactory and how you know not not
thought out their arguments are is I
pointed to the Sunni Shia divide as one
example. Okay. The Sunni Shia divide is
not a political split in its origins.
It's about succession. It's about
Muhammad's bloodline his DNA. Okay. Um
so who are they? Well it's through his
daughter Fatima married to Ali his
cousin and his Hassan and Hussein. and
their progeny, the imams are supposed to
be the leaders of the Muslim world. Now,
you know, I mean, if Muhammad didn't
exist, how does this come about? How did
this happen? You have to have two
co-conspirators, one calls himself
Sunni, one calls himself Shia, who teach
their children to fight and kill each
other over a myth. That's what it means.
And I also pointed out and and just to
show you again, you know, if you're
going to make this up, right, why would
you trace your bloodline through a
woman? Arabs are a very highly
patriarchal culture. Okay? If you're
going to trace your bloodline, you're
going to make make up a h a man, a son
of Muhammad. The fact that it's a woman
actually gives it more credence, makes
it more realistic. It's very it's not
unsimilar to the argument Christian
apologists make, which is one of the
reasons that the gospels are authentic
is the testimony of women, Mary
Magdalene and the others, is why would
they make that up? Why would you
attribute it to women? Because again,
women in that time and in that age,
their testimony is worthless compared to
men. So why would you do it unless it
it's true? So it's the same thing with
the Fatima line, the bloodline. You have
the Fatimids, an entire empire that was
early and it's built on being descended
on the daughter of Muhammad. And Jay's
response to this is, "Oh yeah, this is
some political division by the Ottomans
who are centuries later and it's cast
back to the past." And yet we know that
in the past we have early records of
Shia and Sunnis killing each other
because of of the succession and
Muhammad's bloodline. And it's even
mentioned in early Christian sources.
It's referred to in the Marinite
Chronicle, uh, talking about Ali and and
and and rebellions. And so here again is
history. And once again, Jay just
completely poo poos it and he just
ignores it. And then he introduces
instead, you know, hypothesis and
conjecture after conjecture. And that's
what we have to run with. And it's just,
it's really, it's the more I think about
it, the more it's just mindboggling.
>> Yeah. Um I mean you know like way back
in the day um you know they'd actually
be given some of their arguments. The
nomos would be given some arguments like
huh that that is an interesting point
and stuff like that. Yeah. But it's like
over time it's just
>> it's too much man. It's way it's way too
it's way too much to just uh to just
accept. Uh so we want to uh we want to
check out some uh video clips. Um we're
going to check out some video clips of
some things uh Jay said after your
debate. Um, I was planning on because I
didn't know how long you wanted to stay.
I was planning on doing super chats
after you took off, but I realized some
of these are from you. So, I think I'm
going to uh take a couple at a time here
and there in between various clips. Uh,
and basically everyone who's sending
super chats, if it's uh if it's like
directed just towards me or something
general, I'm probably going to just be
very quick with it. And if it's directed
towards Ibrah uh Raymond Ibrahim, then
um then we can focus a little more on
those. Uh but anyway, will this be a
six-hour stream as well? No. Unless
something really weird happens. Uh, is
Robert the cult leader? No. Interesting.
Robert doesn't have the cult tendency.
So, Robert is not responsible for the
kind of uh cult antics. Robert isn't the
one going around saying if you uh, you
know, if you disagree with him, then
it's because of money or things like
that. So, Robert Robert, I have no
problem with people running the
argument. See where it goes. It's when
it turns into a constant distraction.
And you can't even have a discussion
about Muhammad without these guys coming
in and starting harassing you and stuff
like that.
>> That's why uh
>> that's why I differentiate. I always
say, you know, my beef is with the
radical nomos, the moderate nomos. You
know, if it's your belief and you're
fine with it and you're willing to live
and let live the way I am, that's fine
by me. But it's these guys who are just
literally the radical
>> extremists.
>> Yes.
>> The momoists. Yeah.
>> The terrorists.
>> Yeah. The the terrorist among the momos.
The intellectual terrorists. Uh, hey
Dwood and Raymond Ibrahim, can you guys
point me to a book or something that
explains the names of the Quran chapters
and how their divisions work? Same for
the Hadith as possible. Yeah, as far as
I mean, as far as the Quran, I would
just say get the study Quran. They they
have uh nice little introductions that
explain the the names and so on. You
have anything for
>> No. Okay. Yeah, get get grab the study
Quran and and that'll that'll get you
pretty far. Some cults make people
crazy, others make people crazy for the
zoot.
Hey Raymond, I don't know. Uh I just
posted a video recently where I found
something very interesting. Um it was an
it was a sort of part two of the Elzut
video, but it was uh Mike Jones Mike
Jones who has his channel inspiring
philosophy and he was point I was I was
telling him the story of Elzoot and he
goes that that kind of reminds me of
some stuff I read about this weird
practice in certain places of the
ancient world. But there was a there was
a practice in certain places in the
ancient world where it was it was made
for adolescence where they believed that
grown men injecting inseminating
boys made them stronger men. And so they
had this weird practice where it was
viewed like the more semen you put in
someone the more it was going to grow
you into a strong man. And I was just I
was like oh well if that Muhammad's a
caravan trader if he actually heard
about that from somewhere he could have
thought well I'll be the most powerful
man who ever lived. I will have all the
men of Alz come and inject me with all
their manliness. And I thought that
would give a new meaning to the to that
saying he had the sec he had the
strength of 30 men, right? So it could
actually be a number. He got banged by
30 dudes and that's why he's so that's
why he's so viral. Anyway,
>> but don't forget that was written
because that's that was considered a
cool Matt Macho thing back in 17.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Back in the day they thought
getting banged in the desert. His love
his his pro his followers just thought
that was just awesome.
>> Alz attacked Momo before the Quran
proved him wrong. Islam is a cult. Truth
is not required. I mean Shayan did it.
Start by the cave uh choking verses. Oh
yeah, that would be weird. Um if the
choking if the choking Muhammad in the
cave is actually some weird sexual thing
you guys talking about Muhammad. He was
just here today. Why is my Amazon
delivery driver so important to you
guys? That's the main question. I'll
take one more and then jump into uh some
videos. I really don't understand why
Jay is so adamant about the
non-existence of Muhammad. He goes so
far as to making verifiably false claims
about the Arabic. Yeah, this apostate of
Allah. She's an uh she's an ex-Muslim.
But yeah, that's kind of the issue. That
would be the thing if you just said,
"Hey, here's my theory and you know, go
with it if you want, but it is at it's
so clear and obvious that anyone who
rejects it must be uh must be something
wrong with them." Anyway, let's uh let's
check out some of these uh some video
clips here and then we'll we'll
periodically look at a couple super
chats. But uh which uh which video clip
do you want to do you want to take a
look at? Do you want to go for his uh
little uh prayer that he offered?
>> Yeah, that's that one I definitely want
to comment on.
>> All right. So, this is Jay Smith and
this is his lecture on this issue. This
is after his debate with you, right? do.
>> No, no, this was actually I made my two
little videos and then he made he made
this long lecture in which he says he's
going to respond to me, but of course it
was all straw man stuff and then he
ended it with this. Okay, here we go.
This morning I had to speak at two other
churches, both Calvary Chapel churches.
And one of them I decided to do
something I'd not been done before. I
decided to have a discussion between
Jesus and Muhammad. So I put Muhammad
over here and I was Jesus. I turn out to
be sacrilegious
and I said, "Muhammad, I want to talk to
you about some things. First of all, who
and how can you claim to be a prophet?
You're not in the prophetic line.
You didn't do anything to prove you're a
prophet. All prophets either have to do
a miracle or a prophecy." You didn't do
either. That which you wrote down here
completely confronts what I've written
down from all the other prophets. How
can you completely confront everything
that's in my book?
And then of course you have no idea who
I am. You don't even know my name.
I'm not Allah. Allah is not a name. It's
a title. It means the god. What's my
name? Why is you don't even know my
name?
>> The only significant point there so far
is that uh the Quran refers to Jesus as
Issa. Um apart from that, well, let's
see where he goes.
>> And look what you did to me. You took me
off the cross and put another man in my
place. How dare you do that? And I
started getting indignant, really angry.
And I said, "But by the way, Muhammad,
why did it?" I said, "Where are you?"
"You've disappeared."
"That's right. You never existed."
Look, look. Woman stands up. A woman
stands up. She's so excited about this
powerful.
>> You know what? You can you can pause it
there and because the next part is is
this I want I'd like to comment and
write about this and then there's
something else about the next part.
>> Mhm. And the point here is as you as you
point out you know people stand up and
they clap and this is some like supposed
to be a profound parable or you know
hypothetical scenario and it completely
overlooks the fact that even if this
happened and and Jesus and Muhammad are
talking which is kind of weird because
Muhammad doesn't exist after all but it
doesn't change the fact that two billion
Muslims still believe Jesus wasn't
crucified and wasn't resurrected okay
and that Muhammad did exist. So, you
see, he he gives this sort of feel-good
little narrative and people get up and
clap as if something's been proven when
in the real world, uh, you know, it's uh
business as usual amongst Muslims. They
believe all the the negative stuff about
Jesus that he that made him angry and
that made him want to argue with
Muhammad. So again, so it's such a moot
point, okay? It's so irrelevant and yet
you can see the emotional response that
he gets because it's become part of a
sort of cult uh uh argument.
>> And it's uh it's just so weird because I
mean think about this. We're told
repeatedly in the Bible false prophets
and false teachers are going to come.
We've known about Muhammad being a false
prophet for a long time. We can expose
him as the most obvious false prophet in
history. You can look at all the
biblical criteria of a false prophet. No
one ever ever fulfilled more of these
criteria of a false prophet than
Muhammad. He's the most f most obvious
false prophet in history. And Jay's
basically saying, "But isn't it easier
just to say he didn't exist and then you
don't have to deal with any of that
stuff?" And yay. Yay. Wow. What a what a
brilliant what a brilliant.
>> And it's again it's it's it's this sort
of egoism kind of like, "Oh, you've
convinced me the non-Muslim, therefore
all Muslims must agree because they all
think like I do." it I I I don't I can't
begin to enter such a mentality and how
it actually operates.
>> Yeah. And not uh and and it's not going
to be a case of um you so I mean just
think about this because people are are
dazzled and amazed. They're like whoa
Mahmad was a title for Jesus and all the
church fathers use this and everyone is
using this title for Jesus and that's
where the name Ma Muhammad came from. It
was uh it was it was because of this.
Wow. Wow. I guess Muhammad never did
exist. Oh my goodness. I'm going to go
share this all over the world. You're
guys, do you really think you're you're
never going to run into a Muslim who
actually looks that up and goes, "Uh,
show me show me one church father who
said that. Show me one." You just said
all of it was all over the place.
Everyone's calling everyone's referring
to Jesus as by one. It's not even that.
It's it's the very assumption that a
Muslim would even bother looking into it
is absurd.
>> And they don't they don't take it
seriously,
>> you know? Yeah. Even like even if the
Muhammmed argument wasn't busted as it
was recently, it's still not it's if a
Muslim is not going to be moved by that
any more than a Christian is moved by
the pariclete is it means a comforter
and that's actually also one of
Muhammad's names and therefore so I'm
happy that they exposed it. I'm not
saying that's great. But I'm just trying
to say don't think that if it wasn't
exposed that it was a really strong
argument. It wasn't. even if it really
meant the praised one, that still was
not a strong argument because it doesn't
matter. Every Arabic name means
something like that. So, uh anyway,
>> yeah, guys, that's um that's important.
What Raymond is saying is really
important. He said it earlier, but uh
the example of the the pariclete, right?
So, Muslims when they're when a Muslim
speaker like Zachar is speaking to a
crowd just like this and he says uh he
says uh you know that that John 14 when
it talks about the paraclete is actually
about Muhammad and they say that the the
word was actually modified there and it
actually lines up and and means the same
thing as Ahmed and so on. The entire
Muslim audience will wow this is such
powerful stuff. This is so great.
Does does the fact that Muslims just
will instantly accept what their speaker
is saying, does is that persuasive to
you as a Christian, do you think it's a
good argument because they'll just go
along with it and they'll accept it? No.
You'd say if if if you were at all even
going to take it seriously, you would
look it up, right? You would start
looking things up. But you probably
wouldn't take it seriously at all
because you just be like, "What? The the
the John 14 about the Holy Spirit?
That's actually about Muhammad. Are you
like, are you joking? Um, guess what?
That's that's what that's what Raymond's
point out. Just because Jay can convince
a room full of Christians when he's
giving a bunch of kind of madeup
information. Um, you try and running
that with your argument in running that
with running that argument to Muslims.
What makes you think they're going
they're going to take that seriously?
>> Or look at it this way. Okay. Um, the
way uh um
think about okay, the attack on Christ,
right? the atheist attack that he didn't
exist. You know, Christians went through
this too, right? I find it I I guarantee
you all the people that sit and listen
to J. Smith and just are so into this
and enthralled, they would never bother
looking into the arguments against
Christ's existence, even though they
should because that's much more
important for them, right? I' if if
there's actually an attack on Christ not
existing, I as a Christian, if I took
that seriously, I would have to address
that before I'd worry about Muhammad
because Muhammad's a false prophet in my
mind anyway. Exist or not exist, he has
no relevance for me. And I guarantee
you, the overwhelming majority of the
people who are going out of their way to
listen and follow these arguments who
are Christians will never ever ever
bother to look at arguments against
Jesus. And my point in telling you this
is that's fine. That's human nature. But
so you have to expect that's exactly how
Muslims approach this as well when an
attack on Muhammad's historicity is
leveled by Christians. Do you honestly
think that this shocks them and oh wow
we we need to read the arguments and we
need to respond to them or do they do
what most Christians say which is what a
bunch of nonsense. I'm not even going to
bother looking at it. Especially when we
go back to the principle that I pointed
out which is it can never be proven.
Okay? There's no way with absolute
certainty you can prove Jesus didn't
exist and you can't prove it without
Muhammad because of the nature of
history. So I just I find it funny how
you know a lot of the Christian nomos
they their sort of behavior they don't
understand applies exactly to Muslims uh
and this in the sort of way they would
never once doubt in Jesus based on
whatever argument you can present is
exactly how Muslims even more so Muslims
because Muslims are told in the Quran
Christians and Jews will never rest
until they get you to you know sway you
their way. So they already expect
Christians and Jews to just attack
Muhammad and lie and distort etc etc. So
I don't know I just think they need pe
the Christians especially need to be
cognizant that the same sort of defense
mechanisms that they have instinctively
are amongst Muslims and even more so.
>> Yeah. As evidenced by the fact that you
have tons and tons and tons of nomos
running around and we see almost no
reaction from Muslims. And Jay's
interpretation of that is because the
Muslims are trying to marginalize this.
Uh they're they're trying to keep this
information secret because they know it
will destroy their entire religion
>> because it hides Islam from scrutiny. It
hides their number one Achilles heel is
Muhammad. And if you can hide Muhammad
and if Muhammad doesn't exist, then who
cares about his life? It never happened.
It's all lies. That actually serves
Islam and it helps it to hide as opposed
to what you and I would do, which is
talk about the actual life of Muhammad
as recorded in Islam's own scriptures.
That's so hard for them to deny because
it's their own words. They have to
confront it. But an argument saying he
never existed and somehow I think
Muslims have to contend with it and
prove to me. One of Jay's big thing is
uh and I think you have the video. Uh
I'll wait till you play it. It's the one
where he says, you know, like you have
to prove it to me. You're the one who's
making a claim. Yeah. But you continue
with this one and we'll remark on the
ending.
>> All right. So Jay's about to give his
concluding prayer here in a second. What
a waste of time.
>> What a waste of time examining Muhammad
Muhammad's life and exposing Muhammad's
life, guys. It's a waste of time.
>> I say he never existed.
>> Yeah, you could you could just say you
could just say he never existed and
that'll work wonders even though we've
never seen that work wonders at all.
>> Who would have known?
>> Yeah. Let's pray. Our heavenly father,
we want to thank you for not only who
you are, but the fact you did exist. We
want to thank you that you did come to
earth 2,000 years ago and that you told
us you were going to do so from the very
beginning right there with Adam and Eve
and all the way through history. You
have pointed to who you were and what
you were going to do.
>> We knew your name. We were expecting we
we knew that you were going to call be
called the son of God. We knew that you
were going to be called the Messiah. We
knew that you were going to be called
the son of man. And we knew that you had
a name, Yahweh. What a name. And when
you came, some of us saw you. Some of us
believed you. Many did not. But Lord, we
believed you. We know you existed. We
know you came to earth. And you had to
come to earth because I'm damned if you
didn't.
Thank God you did exist. And thank God
Muhammad didn't.
Because what Muhammad has done to you,
what Muhammad has done to your
scriptures, what Muhammad done is to
your story, what Muhammad has done to
everything that we hold to be to be
dear, I'm so glad he never existed. And
I don't want to waste time anymore on
that man who never existed.
>> Amen.
>> Christ's name we pray.
>> You hear the amens.
>> You say that was so weird. What Muhammad
did, what Muhammad did, what Muhammad
did, what Muhammad did. He never
existed. It's so unthinkable that I'm
glad he didn't exist. So this
non-existent person did all this stuff.
>> So So you see the contradiction there.
But um yeah, exactly. But notice and
here this is the perfect example to me
of how the no m is now becoming
sacralized as part of their faith. Okay.
It's be it's part of the prayer now.
It's we have faith.
>> Yeah. Now you pray about Muhammad not
existing.
>> Yeah. Thank you Lord for Muhammad not
>> Right. Yes. Thank you for that. And we
have faith in that. And that's why when
you and I come and challenge it, we are
fa or infidels. That's what the word
means. We're breaking faith.
>> We're going against the prayers. We're
we're we're interfering with their
prayers and their liturgy now.
>> So, that right there, I think, was a
perfect example of the occultic nature
that this movement is starting to take,
just as it was with the woman who got up
and started, you know, hallelujah
because Muhammad doesn't exist. And even
as he speaks, Jay can't help but
continue contradicting himself. Thank
God that that man who did X, Y, and Z
didn't exist. So then, who did X, Y, and
Z? And does it even matter when we
realize two billion Muslims believe in
X, Y, and Z, including all the negative
stuff they said about the Trinity and
Christ and Christianity? And so, once
again, we go in circles and it's just a
totally moot point. It's wild, wild
stuff. Uh, how do you stop yourself from
zooting Muslims? What's wrong with you?
Um, the WWF era that predates WWE was
fantastic. Loved it.
>> Yeah, that was Ig. Back in the day,
everyone, wrestling was regional and
then they made it uh they made it a much
bigger thing. Uh here we go. I'd love
and appreciate a deep dive into
pre-Islamic Cabba and its ties to modern
Cabba. Is Islam in the synagogue of Bal
Hubal? Is that the second dilemma? How
deeply are the roots set in Hubal? And
uh how much is still present? Well, it's
kind of kind of like you take a ball.
You take everything that was around
Muhammad in 7th century Arabia and you
roll it all up into a ball and you get
Islam. You take a bunch of the the pagan
beliefs and the pagan practices centered
around the Cabba and you take some of
the uh stories that the Jews are telling
and some of the Christians are telling
some of them like by heretical
Christians and so on and some various
pract
and and you roll it up into a ball and
you get Islam. That that's kind of why
they called them called him the ear. You
have any thoughts on that?
>> No, I agree. It's a, you know, it's a
syncratic religion basically at its
root. So you can expect to see all these
various elements.
>> And sketchier says the standard can't
eliminate all historical figures. Yeah,
that would be the problem if you if your
if your methodology could be used to
destroy every historical figure, then
probably need a better methodology.
All right, let's check out the next
video. This will be um what Jay said
about your claim that he's responding to
uh which should be interesting.
What the people are pushing back on is
Muhammad itself. They want to they want
to say yes you we there is so much
historical support for Muhammad more so
remember what Raymond said more so than
for Jesus Christ. What a
>> Yeah. Uh, it's good to know that you
said Raymond Ibrahim, you said there's
more historical evidence and support for
Muhammad than for Jesus. Let me just
>> keep playing it cuz he's gonna he's
going to poo poo me.
>> I'm gonna play it. Yeah. I just wanted I
just wanted people to catch this and
then I'm going back so we can see him
say it again. And then
>> it hurts his feelings that I I say this.
>> Yeah. I can't believe I can't believe
you say such a thing. Uh I want to end
this live stream right now because we've
got Raymond Ibrahim who says such
terrible things about Jesus
>> pushing back on is Muhammad itself. They
want to they want to say yes you we
there is so much historical support for
Muhammad more so remember what Raymond
said more so than for Jesus Christ. What
a statement to make.
>> I had to take that off.
>> Explain explain for our audience who
Raymond is because you talk about it in
the presentation but they haven't heard
All right, let me just respond to what
he's talking about. So, as you can see,
according to J. Smith, I said there's
more um there's more historical support
for Muhammad than Jesus. And then, of
course, you know, he he seems so
disappointed because again, that's the
part where he's trying to show that I'm
being a bad Christian, right? I mean,
what if there was more historic support?
Does that make it that I'm a bad
Christian? But the point is, I actually
never said that. What I did is something
that rather annoyed him during our
debate is I basically quoted uh his hero
and and the the person who literally
wrote the book about you know casting uh
uh skepticism and doubt about early
Islamic history and that's Patricia
Crona in her book Hagarism and and David
Cook. I actually quoted an AR article
that she wrote before she died and I'll
read to you the portion that got him
really upset. Uh so the article that she
wrote is called uh what we what we
actually know about Muhammad. Patricia
Cron and she writes look quote
um we probably know more about Muhammad
than we do about Jesus let alone Moses
or the Buddha. There is no doubt that
Muhammad existed. Muhammad is the only
founder of a world religion who is
attested in a contemporary source. All
right. So I read these during our
debates and that's what he's referring
to. I didn't say that. It's the person
who actually spearheaded the claims
against Muhammad who he presents as one
of his heroes who actually said that. Uh
so the two points actually to emphasize
here is and one yeah it's actually true
because and that doesn't make me a bad
Christian. I'm just speaking about
history. I'm not if if you say Muhammad
there was more sources about him that
doesn't mean that Jesus didn't exist. It
just so happened to be that at that time
people writing and recorded more about
Muhammad than they did about Jesus.
Again, that doesn't and I'm talking
about non non-believers, non-Christians
and non-Muslims.
>> So, hang on. In other in other words,
you would say there's more historical
evidence about uh Donald Trump than
there is about Jesus.
>> Yeah. Which would make you an atheist,
of course, if you say that by J by J.
Smith's reasoning, right? Um, so but but
again, you know, here but I love how he
just evades the fact that it's not I
that said that I quoted his hero who he
tries to present as being the source who
says Muhammad never existed. And here
here she's flat out saying that yeah, of
course he existed.
>> So and uh for people who don't
understand the significance, this is
kind of where a lot of this stuff takes
off with uh Patricia Crona. Um so she's
one of the pioneers of what's called the
revisionist school. of Islam, namely
that, hey, we need to revise everything
we uh, you know, the basically the
standard narrative and so on and take a
more critical look at it. But then she's
pointing out, and I've seen people quote
her as someone who denied Muhammad's
existence. And she, no, Muhammad
definitely existed,
>> saying Muhammad definitely existed. We
have a ton of historical information
about him. And so you quote that, you
quote that to Jay during your debate to
say, "Hey, this is one of your heroes."
And she's saying, "We have uh we have
enough evidence about Muhammad's
existence to conclude he definitely
existed
>> more than Jesus, Muhammad, more than
Jesus, Moses, and Buddha."
>> And and uh it's so disappointing that
you'd be uh throwing that in. Um
>> Yeah. Exactly. It just shows my how I'm
not a real Christian. Yeah. I've got
more to this clip. Was that Was that
what you wanted to see there?
>> Uh yeah, you can probably play more.
>> Oh, let's see. Let's see. Well, it's uh
it's um
we've got uh Frank Turk asking about you
and then Jay's responding that you've
actually done good work except on this
issue
>> about it on this show yet. Who's
Raymond?
>> Okay, sorry. Raymond Ibrahim. I've never
met him, but I love the guy. The guy is
great. Uh I he's done me a favor because
Muslims won't take won't take me on on
this. They would rather just I not say
anything and that I just I I just walk
away in irrelevancy because they don't
want the world to hear what we're saying
or what we're finding. This is a whole
new pmic. It's called the historical
pmic, the external pmic that has that
they have they're not ready for. And
they you can see why in every other pmic
the stuff that you saw me using that
stuff that you and I use at speaker's
corner they would rather us engage in
that because then you're talking about
the interpretation of scripture and they
always say we interpret it better than
you do that they can walk away from
those kind of discussion but they can't
walk away from this. So this Raymond
Ibrahim, he is actually I think he's
from the west coast. I don't know
exactly where he lives. He he is an
Egyptian cop
from the Coptic church, but he is has
grown up in America, so he has an
American accent, speaks Arabic
beautifully and he has an entire show
called a Raben Ibraim.
Go look at it. He is really doing what
you're doing, what many others are
doing, but really in the Islamic
context. He is using what we call the
internal form of pyics. internal means
taking the Quran, opening it up, reading
its pages, and then attacking it.
Looking at Muhammad and what it says
about, well, it doesn't say much about
Muhammad, but about the prophet and
attacking it. That's called internal
critique. You look at what Muslims
believe at what they're saying and you
confront that. That's what I did for 30
years. Now, I've come with the external
critique and Abraham doesn't like uh
Raymond doesn't like it. He thinks it's
the weakest of all pymics.
>> Wait, is Raymond
>> I also think it's uh the weakest of
pymics. Let me see. Back this up.
Doesn't like it. He thinks it's the
weakest of all pymic.
>> Wait, is Raymond a Muslim or a
Christian?
>> He's a Christian.
>> He's a Coptic. He's a Coptic church.
>> Okay. So, he is a Coptic Christian. But
he's trying to say that Islam or
Muhammad is well supported. And you say
in your presentation, you go through his
10 points and you refute each one of
them.
>> Every one of them. Yeah. No, there are
more than 10, but
>> uh I haven't seen this debate. So, this
is after the debate.
>> No, no, this is Okay. So, I made my two
videos and then um you know the video we
just watched where Jay makes his prayer.
>> Uhhuh.
>> That long video in front of that church
supposedly he he responded to supposedly
10 points I made.
>> Okay. And as I pointed out later, most
of those points I had never even said.
They were just and that's why they were
total straw men. And the points I did
make, he actually like the the Shia
thing, he just completely like bypassed
it immediately. Um and then we had our
debate. Hm. Might be super interesting
at some point if we uh I'm not talking
about you and me. I mean uh we
Christians in some some some Christians
would want to uh basically play each one
of your points and then see how he
responded in there and and see how it
actually uh responds to what you're
saying. That might be fun.
>> Yeah, I didn't even make 10 points. the
that that was the other thing is a lot
of those points were I think points that
he set up because he wanted to knock
down and they weren't even part of my my
arsenal. It was just two very short
videos I made and and most of them were
about the seventh century attestations
from non-Muslims um and the Shia thing.
It was actually three points is what I
did. It was the Shia thing, the
attestation 7th century and the argument
from embarrassment. Um and I use them in
that order. Okay. And uh and he he
really I think he spent like 30 seconds
on those, but in the two-hour video he
spent them on these other arguments that
I never even said and presented them as
if they were mine, which is fine,
whatever. Um, that's not, you know,
>> I mean, it was he was attacking the uh
the standard Islamic narrative, which by
the way, I want to go on record and say
I don't think it should be another
reason that the standard Islamic
narrative gets just immediately
dismissed honestly is because it's
written by Muslims and uh just people
are being hostile. Oh, they're Muslims
or liars. I'm not going to buy into it.
I'm not going to believe it. There's be
and the other reason is, oh, it's so
late. Well, it's not that late when you
compare it to other historical documents
that we accept. All right. Uh, as you
know, Jay, when he dates them and he
gives him these very, very late dates,
he's talking about extent manuscripts
that still exist. And he won't say that,
oh, well, it's based on something older.
And as I pointed out to him, if we're
going to go by this kind of logic is, so
if you're not aware or the viewers
aren't aware, Jay's argument is that
let's say um the mata, okay, which is a
hadith and does mention Muhammad uh and
it's supposed to be maybe like 120 years
after Muhammad, which is not very late,
but he'll argue, well, the extent
manuscript is like uh 500 years after.
>> Yeah.
>> And therefore, you can't trust it.
>> What's that?
>> He does this with Iban Assoc. Well, you
don't even actually have you don't have
the original copy of Iban Assoc. You've
got a later ascension by Iban Hashem and
stuff and yeah,
>> so
>> and then you don't even have the
original of that and so on. And so it's
uh yeah, it's it's a situation. By the
way, just just so this is one of the
issues that bothers me uh about all of
this. It's you'll take someone like Iban
Associer
people. Ibnak is written about 12 120
years after the time of the events he's
reporting. But he's quoting all these
people who are earlier and saying I got
it from this guy and he got it from this
guy and this guy said in his book and
this guy said in that source and this
guy said in this source but we don't
have those sources anymore.
>> And so the conclusion is well therefore
they never existed and uh later later
guys are making this up. It's like where
where are you getting that from? I mean
we we deal with this we deal with this
in Christianity right? I mean you have
you have pe you have people quoting like
Papius and so on. It's like you don't
have Papius anymore. You don't have
that. you have later people quoting it.
Matter of fact, if you even if you go
back like the prescratic philosophers,
these are philosophers before u before
Socrates. You don't have their writings.
You have people like Aristotle quoting
them
>> and saying they said this. I just
imagine if you use this methodology on
anything else. You don't have the
original. It's it never happened.
>> And and the ultimate the ultimate
example which I used and he didn't have
an answer for or I'll give you his
answer is well what about the Old
Testament? Okay. Uh, do you know that
the extent fragments of the Old
Testament, the oldest ones are about
maybe 1,200 years after Moses, who
supposedly wrote the first five books?
By Jay's standards, that's all garbage.
Throw it out. We can't believe it. It's
all lies. It's all hearsay. Let alone
what precedes Moses, Adam, and Eve, and
all the way to him. So you see by his
very logic and when I brought this up
again he just shoot it away and said oh
Raymond nobody's nobody's expecting to
find uh you know uh Old Testament it's
because it's so old as opposed to the
Islamic stuff. Really? You think that's
going to work with a Muslim? If I'm a
Muslim and I say, "Oh, you're saying my
the hadith and the S and whatever, we're
only going to go by extent versions and
we can't trust that it was copied on
something older." And you're and then
when I ask you about the Old Testament
and as a Muslim, as you know, we believe
Muslims believe that the both the the
the Bible Old and New Testament was uh
meaning it was uh it was tampered with,
right? So, you're going to tell me, "Oh,
well, we don't have it either. the the
newest one we have or the oldest one we
have is 12 centuries after the original.
That just proves the Muslim point,
right? That oh well, there you go. Then
obviously it was distorted. You don't
have the original one. So my point is,
you see how you know it's he's taking
this sort of almost it's it's an
immature approach. You know, I'll attack
your books and I'll put it at the
highest standard and the highest bar for
them to pass. But when it when the same
argument perfectly applies to my
scriptures, oh well, you know, no one's
looking for it because this is this is
the Bible. We don't we're not going to
do that. I mean, come on. This is
supposed to be a debate with a
non-believer. I don't know.
>> Yeah. And um I was just uh I just
brought this up at as an example in a
recent live stream, but I was talking
about the Satanic Verses. Um, I have 50
Muslim sources on the satanic verses, 50
of them, and was was asking people was
asking the the nomos like, "How do you
explain this?" Because if you want to
say someone invented the story, like
it's not just inventing the story, it's
inventing a ton of different versions
traced back to a a ton of different
people. And they're all they all claim
they're quoting this guy and quoting
this guy and quoting this and quoting
that and so on. So, if you're talking
about fabrication, you're not just
fabricating a story. You're fabricate
you're you're fabricating a ton of
sources and not only that you're
fabricating like the different layers as
it because the the original story the
original story is the worst. It's
Muhammad he he Satan took control of
Muhammad's emotions and then use
Muhammad's desire to reach his own
people uh use that to slip a false
revelation promoting shik and polytheism
and stuff and Muhammad fell for it and
he delivers the satanic verses to his
followers. his followers, he bows down
in honor of the satanic verses. His
followers bow down and then the pagans
bow down as well. And then later on,
Gabriel comes up to him and says, "Hey,
what'd you do?" Uh, and Satan tricked
you, man. He duped you. What's wrong
with you? You just committed. And then
Muhammad has to repent and so on. Um,
but I mean, you you look at the earliest
version, the earliest version, and then
you look at, you know, the version from
a generation later when it gets watered
down, and then it was Muhammad didn't
say it. Muhammad didn't say it. Satan
imitated his voice and his followers
thought it was Muhammad speaking, right?
And you go later still and they water it
down more until you get to the time of
Bukari. Bkari gives the basic story of
all the polytheist for some reason
mysteriously bowing down in honor of
Surah 53, but there's no reason for it.
And
>> it's very realistic. The the
transmission is very realistic. It's
what you would expect people would
behave and how they would edit it based
on what it really happened. You know,
it's not something that, oh, we just
randomly make it up in this sequence
because it's for whatever.
>> Yeah. And uh so I was asking the Nomos,
how do you explain that? And they were
saying, I kid you not, the main
explanation was maybe a later ruler
wanted to draw more attention to himself
and make himself look by look good by
comparison. And therefore, he made up
this story about Muhammad and and
imposed it on the people and so on. But
I mean, think about this because he
didn't just say, "Let me make up a story
about Muhammad." saying, "Let me make up
the original story and trace that back
to a bunch of guys and then the next
generation's watered down version and
then the next generation's watered down
version and so and it's like what what
level of insane G it right now it
reminds me of like what Muslims say
about Jews, how they're like plot,
they're coming up with all these
diabolical brilliant plots and so on.
It's like how brilliant do you think
these guys were that it's going to be
completely irrelevant at his time?" But
he's like, "You know what? more than a
thousand years from now, there's going
to be people looking at this
historically, and I want to be able to
show how this story is being watered
down and so on over time, and I'm going
to attribute it to to 50 to 50 sources.
And so, it's like I seriously
>> all that to prove my point. That's
what's going on. This is all sophistry,
okay? And absurd conjecturing and
hypothesizing to prove my agenda or or
or, you know, the Nommo agenda
basically. um instead of like you said
Oak's razors and just you know it's
plain in front of you what happened
right it's just very obvious
>> yeah so yeah that's all opposed to the
obvious Muhammad delivered the sanetic
verses it was a huge embarrassment and
so Muslims knew it was embarrassing and
you know as the farther they get away
from it the more they water it down
>> that makes perfect sense it's exactly
what you would expect it's exactly what
you would expect them to do
>> exactly
>> and somehow it's actually the reverse
it's a later guy invents a story and
then makes it more extreme in the
sources as you get closer. It's just
really really weird stuff. Uh but let's
let them this is about to get uh uh
there's about a minute left of this but
check this out.
>> The 10 major points, right? And so what
he is and you can see for he for an
awful lot of Christians who have like
David Wood is the same way or hatunsh my
colleague they are all trying to shut me
down because if
>> everyone have you ever once up until we
very recently started attacking the
position because now he wasn't just
saying it about me he was saying it
about my friends and so on and because
he was getting exposed for using just
completely madeup information. You ever
have you ever heard me try to shut Jay
Smith down
>> once?
>> Me neither.
>> Anytime. Yeah.
>> Instead, this this comes up regularly in
conferences.
>> He said that in the in the video, you
know, the the two-hour video where he
says the prayer. He said that about me
like five times. Raymond Ibrahim's this
guy who's trying to shut me down.
>> Yeah. We're Yeah, because we're trying
to cover up the truth because we're
evil, everyone. Um but guys, think about
this.
He's making he makes up that we're
trying to shut him down and then makes
up the motivation for why we're trying
to shut him down. So guys, if you've uh
paid attention in live streams and at
conferences and stuff where this comes
up in the Q&A, you can go back every
single time I've been asked about this.
What do I say every single time? Because
it's what I it's what I believed. Said I
don't believe Muhammad existed, but I
understand there are all sorts of
problems with the Muslim sources and so
you can be more skeptical than I am and
so on. But I think it's great that we're
we're we're running different arguments
and see where they go. And eventually if
it if it doesn't work out, it doesn't
work out. But sometimes if especially if
you got like a newer argument like the
ones Jay's using, uh sometimes you have
to run the argument and and see see
where it leads and see where it goes.
So, yep. I'm in favor of uh running all
these arguments. That's what I've said
every single time. What does he say?
What does he say when he's representing
what happened? I'm trying to shut him
down. And he's about to give the reason.
the reason we're all trying to shut him
down and he he tossed did he say that
Hatun Hatun's been trying to shut him
down is that
>> I think so
>> let's see let's see all trying to shut
me down because ifs who have like David
Wood is the same way or Hatunsh my
colleague they are all trying to shut me
down because if there was no Muhammad
then where are they going to go for all
their great work all their great
material to attack him if we really
believed he didn't exist wouldn't we all
just go in that direction and say we can
wreck Islam like this.
>> We don't one we don't we don't we don't
believe that. I don't even know where
Hatun stands on this issue anymore. Uh
because she listens to Jay's stuff. Um
but if if we thought there was a a a
better argument that was actually
correct and this could be used to
destroy us, wouldn't we just go with
that, Jay?
>> Well, no. I think he's being more
cynical. I think he's trying to suggest
what I pointed to earlier, which is kind
of like this is our bread and butter, so
we don't want Muhammad.
>> I'm saying I'm saying on the theor given
the theory that it's our bread and
butter, why wouldn't our bread and
butter just switch to Muhammad didn't
exist? I mean, obviously their audience
their audience is full of Christians who
love it. They love it.
>> So why not why wouldn't we just let's
jump on the Jay bandwagon?
>> That that's definitely an option. But
the real point is it it doesn't matter
what you guys the nomos are saying.
Muslims two billion still believe in in
Islam and therefore our job security is
fine despite what you guys tell
yourselves in your echo chamber. That's
the point. He's trying to act as if um
because once again it's because they say
there's no Muhammad Erggo. Every Muslim
also agrees and guess what? The
narrative's falling apart and you and I
have nothing to talk about anymore. No,
sorry. Believe all you want about no
Miy. Uh the Muslims don't and they're
still going strong and believing in
their faith just as they always have. So
yeah, job security is fine on that end
if that was the case.
>> Yeah. So in other words, there would be
even if we thought Jay had the truth,
>> we would have no reason to think that
this would be a problem for all the
gravy train to continue because,
>> you know, he could spend he could spend
the rest of his life arguing this.
There's still tons of people to reach
and therefore we'd have an endless
supply of people to uh criticize
Muhammad to
>> regardless. So, in other words,
>> uh, false that we've been trying to shut
him down. False that this is our
motivation. He can't get his mind around
the fact that anyone just disagrees with
him and doesn't, especially when we look
at his arguments and it's, "Did you know
that all the church fathers were saying
Makmoud is a title for Jesus?" And then
it turns out to be completely bogus.
Back this up a little.
>> No, Muhammad. Then where are they going
to go for all their great work, all
their great material to attack him?
>> There's nothing else to talk about.
>> Well, yeah, but the Muslims believe
Muhammad existed. So David's doing it an
internal critique as you say
>> that, you know, Muhammad, you know,
married young people and had 15 wives
and and did many awful things. You know,
he cut the head off of all these Jews.
He said, "Kill any Jew under your
power." You know, he did all these what
we would say are evil things. And so
David's taken that approach. You've
tried that for 30 years and it hasn't
gotten many converts.
>> What planet has this guy been living on?
You've been trying this. So Jay's been
using he Jay's been attacking Muhammad
for 30 years and it hasn't seen where's
he been?
>> I've seen tons and tons and tons and
tons and tons of and matter of fact
almost every almost every person I've
ever seen who left Islam left Islam
after finding out all this stuff about
Muhammad. That's when they start
doubting Islam. That's when they start
doubting Islam. And apparently Jay's
just been living in some alternative
reality. The the apostasy rate among
young Muslims went from around 0% 20
years ago to 26% most recently. What is
that? Is it because of the powerful
evidence that Muhammad never existed?
No. It's because we made the information
more common knowledge. So now Muslims
are finding out about it more and more.
They're finding out, hey, everything I
was told all my life by my imam does not
line up with what my own sources say.
that leads to an that's led to the
avalanche of apostasy
>> and then Jay's saying ah no one no one
no one that doesn't work that's why we
needed to go in this next direction
where again I've never seen one Muslim
leave Islam there may be there may be
Muslims who have left because of this
I've never seen one of them and so the
idea that this is just more effective
and that that that old approach doesn't
work
>> that's if that if that's if that's what
Jay is saying now this was just Frank
interpreting what Jay said as this I
don't know if Jay said that earlier in
the talk or something like that but if
Jay's actually. Yeah. If Jay's actually
saying that this doesn't work. This is
what really works.
>> Oh, no. He said that. He said that in uh
in our debate. I mean, he said that. Um
and and you know, just to sort of
elaborate on what you're saying, and I
pointed this out before, but I'm privy
to another window that most people are
not to because I'm an Arabic speaker and
I watch pmics against Islam from former
Muslims, from you know, Abua's father
Zachary Butra's brother Rasheed.
Thousands of people were leaving Islam
from their
>> and all of their pmics are based on the
character and nature of Muhammad not his
dis non-existence. No one no Arab
speaker who was is like you saying
thousands if not millions of Muslims are
are causing them to leave Islam engages
in that argument. They all engage in the
internal so-called internal argument
based on the character and nature of
Muhammad because it's so by nature
powerful. You're fighting fire with
fire. Muslims can't evade the points
that we make, which is it's your book.
I'm going by your book. Your book says
this, and now I'm asking you to use your
reason and say, "Is it good for a
prophet to act this way? Is this just
for him to treat women like sex slaves
and you can have as many sex slaves as
you capture and you can, you know, sleep
with young children and everything
else?" Okay, that is a powerful
argument. And as that's why I think we
were talking earlier, you showed that
poll which showed the number one reason
Muslims leave is because of the nature
and character of Muhammad. And that poll
did not show didn't even show that
Muslims leave Islam because they think
it didn't exist at all. It wasn't even
the top uh I think it was five points
that it showed. It wasn't even number
five. Um so it's just it's absurd.
Again, it makes you wonder, you know,
what's the motive here? um that he would
actually say that the the argument that
does work is the one that doesn't work
and the one that doesn't work is the one
that has to work even though it doesn't
even make sense and it's so ineffective
because it doesn't make sense.
>> Yeah. And it's um it's very interesting
to me because uh back in the day if you
go back 20 years uh in Christianity in
America it was taken as standard just
standard even in churches that are
talking about how to witness to Muslims
and how to uh convert Muslims and so on.
It was standard. Never criticize
Muhammad. never criticized the Quran.
And when I was hearing this, it's like,
okay, I only knew of a couple converts
back then. But it was like hearing that
all the all the things they were taught
about Muhammad were were false according
to their own sources was a huge part.
And churches are saying, "Don't ever
share this stuff because you'll hurt the
Muslims feelings and you're going to
drive him away and he's never going to
listen to you. So just preach the gospel
and don't ever criticize Muhammad or the
Quran." And I'm sitting there thinking,
all of my experience goes against every
all of my experience with Muslims like
flies in the face of that. And you so
where where's this actually coming? It
was funny because I actually traced it
to where they were getting it from. One,
they were getting it from missionaries
to Muslim countries, right, who' come
back and speak at churches and stuff.
I'm like, it makes sense if you're a
missionary in Saudi Arabia not to go
around criticizing Muhammad. That makes
sense. What's that got to do with us in
the US, right? Uh, and the other place
they were getting it from was um
interfaith dialogues where you'd have
like a Muslim speaker and a Christian
speaker and a Jewish speaker and they
all get together and they said and the
Muslim speaker told us, "Isn't it great
to build bridges, but if you start
criticizing Muhammad in the Quran,
you're not going to have these bridges
anymore and we're not going to want to
talk to you." So, and I'm I'm just
sitting there going, can you say that
with a straight face that you tell that
you think the Muslim speaker at an
interfaith event was giving you valuable
information on how to reach Muslims with
the gospel? like you that's what you're
taking seriously because I have to say
if I heard a if I heard a Muslim speaker
telling me how to reach Muslims with the
gospel, I'd probably automatically
believe the opposite of what he's saying
because I don't think he's going to
actually be trying to tell you how to uh
how to reach Muslims with the gospel and
so on. So anyway, um but it it was funny
because back then, you know, I was like
all my experience is telling me one
thing and and uh if you go like 2009 or
so now I'm already seeing tons of people
leaving Islam and stuff like that. Uh,
but I was I was on they put they put me
on stage with uh uh Zachariah Bros and
and I was like because I was familiar
with him and he that's back when he had
like a $50 million b al-Qaeda bounty on
his head and stuff like that. But I was
hearing about all these thousands of
converts from this guy's talks and stuff
and I was like all the Arab guys who are
seeing thousands of converts
are blasting away at Muhammad. They're
just blasting away and they're they're
they're exposing they're exposing
Muhammad left and right. And you've got
all these churches and at best they'll
say, you know, after 17 years of reach
pre preaching to this Muslim, he he
converted and stuff like that. And it's
like,
uh, I'm going to listen to these guys
because what they're saying is exactly
what what all my experience has shown.
And you've got something and you're
saying it and I don't know where you're
getting it from, but I've never seen any
evidence that this is the great
position. But keep in mind even back
then I was like okay if you want to just
preach the gospel go ahead. But if you
want to just if you don't want to
criticize Muhammad or criticize the
Quran that's I think it's great if
you're going around and you're just
going to preach the gospel that's great.
It's great because there there probably
are Muslims who've already been
wrestling with issues and stuff like
that and you come along you preach the
gospel. That could that could be great.
>> But I it's got to it's it has to be
important to blast away um at Islam. So
I've always been fine with different
approaches. It's when you come along and
say, "No, this is the only way to do
things and anyone else is anyone else
who does anything else is wrong." And
it's uh it gets kind of weird. But now
now we've gone kind of full circle and
now we're on to Yeah. Yeah. It's a waste
of time to argue all this stuff where
that we've seen thousands and thousands
and thousands that of of people leave
Islam, all that stuff. Big waste of
time. Don't follow that path,
Christians. Just start arguing Muhammad
never existed.
And and again I've watched multiple news
programs and talk shows in Arabic on
satellite and they complain they
complain literally about how Zachariah
Butras and brother Rashid and and and
the pmicists that they are making
Muslims leave Islam and what is their
method what is their pic. It's
absolutely 100% about the nature of
Muhammad. Okay that is so for anyone to
ever argue that that is weak or that is
ineffectual. I mean that's crazy. That
is the number one tried and trueue
palemic that every Muslim cites and even
and even Muslims who are angry about
this like I told you when I watch these
shows that's what they point to. Um and
that's why that will get you killed. I
have yet to hear anyone complain about
oh these these guys are casting doubt in
the existence of Muhammad. I'm sorry I
just haven't. That doesn't happen. Um,
again, if if someone wants to use that
and wants to preach nomy, that's fine by
me. As long as they're moderate nomos,
but when they become, you know,
canankerous and all fight with us,
>> okay, then I have an issue.
>> Yeah, we've got all these radical nomos
coming out of the closet. It's creepy.
>> Um,
uh, Dr. Ibrahim, how special were the
martyrs of Otranto?
>> Well, I mean, for those who don't know,
the martyrs of Toronto, I actually wrote
made a video about and wrote about it.
It was their anniversary. it was recent
and it's basically um um the the
Ottomans invaded Italy or Toronto and um
they massacred all the Italians and then
they had like 813 captive men and they
enslaved the women and children and they
tried to be magnanimous and they said
okay all you have to do is renounce
Christ and embrace Islam and one of the
men said you know what we fought with
our we fought for our land and we lost
now it's time to fight for our souls and
every one of the 813 refused and they
were decapitated ritually and their
archbishop was sawn in half um to cries
to Allah Akbar and um you know and again
so it's very important until today we
have their skulls in in the church of a
Toronto there's an actual um uh glass
case that has all their skulls these
hundreds of Christians and again so you
know what what makes what is more what
helps a person understand an event like
that that Muhammad II who was the actual
sultan at the time was following his
prophet as he said he was or that this
is all a big lie and a big conspiracy
and Muhammad never existed. You see how
this just introduces so so many
complexities that are just unnecessary
and that just trip up non-Muslims and
Christians who are trying to make sense
of events
>> and and that it's Jesus is actually at
the root of all this because it was all
about Jesus originally and it was a
bunch of Christians uh doing this stuff
who started this all off
>> calling themselves the praised ones and
killing other Christians and it just uh
>> Hey, check this out. This stream is too
hunky hard to focus. We know we have
that. we have that effect on people.
Uh were the e were there Ethiopian
knights in the crusades?
>> Don't know if ever studied that.
>> Depends on what you mean by knights um
you know in in the European fashion.
Probably not. But I do believe I mean
there might be because Ethiopians were
Christians of course u at the time. So I
don't know. I'm not going to conject.
I'm not Jay Smith to conjecture. So
>> yeah. Well, you just make up a bunch of
stuff that works. Uh Raymond, finish
your sword and scimitar. Good book. and
good and going to order another.
>> Great. Glad to hear it.
>> And I will uh if you're watching this
later, I will add uh links to Raymond's
books um in the description here. They
won't be here now, but I'll do that
later. And can the relationship Muhammad
had with the men of Alz be used to make
the argument that Islam is actually LGBT
plus inclusive? Um, you know, you know
what's
>> not really cuz he tried to hide it so it
wasn't publicly celebrated because he
did it out in the desert. Um, so you
know, it was still uh not being
celebrated like June the June stuff. It
it's actually interesting um because
this this popped up recently, but when I
was making the video, the sort of part
two on the men of Alz and uh how there
was this weird belief of that men could
inject their manliness into other men
and so on. Um, as I was as I was uh
quoting some passages, some of them were
like, "How long um homosexuality
continued in the Muslim world
relationships and their obsession with
uh young boys, you couldn't you couldn't
you couldn't officially do it, but it's
all it's all it's it was very common
practice for uh up until up until
Western nations started making them stop
this stuff." Um,
>> but it was interesting because um,
uh, someone pointed out someone sent a
link to one of Paul Williams posts, but
Paul Williams is uh, a a gay Muslim
apologist and, uh, one of his links was
to, uh, homosexuality in the Muslim
world and so on. So anyway, there but
point is there are a couple people who
would want to who might want to uh, use
the story of Alz. So, Paul Williams, you
want to use a story of alz to uh to
defend things? I might want to try that.
Very impressive. And uh Raymond says
words, "What my brain hears biceps?"
It's true. And Dr. Ibrahim, how about
some speculative history? What if the
Mongols had converted to Christianity?
Would the crusades have been different?
How so? We don't have time for a lot of
speculation here.
>> They think I'm J. Smith. Well, actually,
the that was one of the um the one of
the motivations of the Crusaders. They
thought the Mongols were the people of
Prester John, this mythical Christian
king from the far east who was going to
come and help them do a Pinsir movement
against Islam. Um, so and some of them
did convert to notorianism, uh, you
know, Christians, but a lot of them like
the like like the Golden Horde of course
converted to Islam. But yeah, if um and
there were alliances between Mongols and
crusaders against Muslims,
but in the end, you know, the Mongols
broke up and a lot of them were Muslim
did convert to Islam and they became a
scourge of Eastern Europe, especially
towards Russia and the Slavic nations,
the golden the golden horde. So,
>> and uh for some
>> and those are facts, not conjectures,
just so you know. You know what else is
a fact that we've got there's just tons
of comments about uh alz from the
leather straps of the anus to the men of
alz. We have come far.
>> I'm gonna have to make a I'm gonna have
to make another video about alz. I've
been thinking about it and there's other
things to add.
>> There can never be too many videos about
alut.
>> Can't be enough al.
>> Yeah. Yeah. The more the more alzier.
That's what Muhammad said and that's
what we say now.
But yeah, you have uh uh sun and abadaw
203 which where Muhammad said the eyes
are the leather strap of the anus. So we
popularized that for a while. Now
everyone knows about alz. And here you
have al zut split Muhammad's moon. Yeah
it's the origin of the of uh uh
splitting the moon. Also uh could call
it Muhammad's real night journey. U but
can AP remake the AC/DC song you shook
me all night long and make it about
Muhammad and Alz I bet. I bet he I bet
he can. Um, and uh, one more one more
and then we'll jump into the next uh,
little clip. The kill shot for Nommo is
how Momo died like an idiot. Why would
you make up that your prophet died the
death of false prophet? So yeah, they're
talking about Muhammad dying by
poisoning, especially after whole
woman's whole family gets all the men in
her family get killed by Muslims and
then she offers to cook dinner.
Muhammad's like, "Duh, yeah, I like
food."
>> Who would make this stuff up? I'm trying
to create this heographical awesome
prophet to legitimize my Arab empire and
from top to bottom it's just full of
warts and flaws and
>> not bottom in the in the alz sense just
to be clear.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. And that's the thing and and when
you when I I think I've asked no the
nomos for this before and they said
maybe Muhammad was blaming a Jewish
woman for poisoning him because they
wanted to stir up host more hostility
against Jews. It's like, wait, if you
could make up anything, why not why have
him being a complete idiot? Why not say
he he went out and fought them, you
know, violent, you know, in battle and
fought valiantly and something like that
or they assassinated him or something
like why do you got to why do you have
to make him the idiot of the story?
>> Well, apparently because that was cool
for seventh century Arabs.
>> Yeah, it was just we don't we didn't
know it back then, but back then
>> like an idiot prophet.
>> Yeah. Being the dumbest person in the
world was just super cool.
>> We just don't get it because we're
modern people. Yeah.
>> Yeah. We're modern people. We think that
we think it's stupid to uh die over a
roasted lamb.
>> Um anyway, here's a here's a clip of Jay
on the burden of proof.
>> It's not me to prove. Raymond wants me
to prove he didn't exist. How can you
prove he didn't exist?
>> Mhm.
>> That's a nonsecar. He has to prove that
he existed since he's making the claim.
So therefore, if he in order for him to
make the claim, he has to prove that
this man was called Muhammad, that he
lived in a place called Mecca, that he
received a book called the Quran, not
just bits and pieces fragments, all 114
suras, and that this all happened before
632. They have to everybody now has and
every Muslim has to answer those four
questions. How can you do that as a
Muslim? And I actually want to tie that
together with his uh claim about the
topic here because that's that's also
short clip. But let's see
in the debate that I did last week with
uh Raymond Ibraim when you look at the
debate it was a debate that was set up
really to answer the question who is or
did the Muhammad of Islam exist? That
was the type
>> he sounded like he was about to say
who's the real Muhammad. Um but he he
set he switch the goalpost is always
changing. So yeah. Yeah. Let's see what
he says.
>> Who is or did the Muhammad of Islam
exist? That was the title of the debate.
At least it was the title that we
challenged Raymond to because of the
fact that he came up very clearly in his
two videos in April saying, "I don't
even have to look at Jay's videos. I
know how to prove that Muhammad
existed." It turns out that Muhammad
that he was supporting is really a
historical Muhammad
>> or uh whichever way you want it of
history, not the Muhammad of Islam. He
did not want to take that on. I now
understand why he wanted to go first. I
couldn't figure out why he wanted to go
first since we were doing the challenge.
It would make sense that we I would go
first.
>> I didn't want to go first. It was
offered to me and I said, "Okay." Yeah.
Because I'm the one who started this by
making my videos. I'll make my points.
But just to um And just obviously you
would be the affirmative usually goes
first unless there's some weird reason
for the
>> and not to mention I thought it would I
thought the first is actually the weaker
position because the second one now has
ammo you know whereas I'm just talking.
So anyway so first of all for him to say
that this wasn't the agreed topic just
to just to show you how it's not true.
Okay he already mentioned my two videos.
My two videos like I told you I didn't
make 10 points. Anyone can watch them.
They're online. I made three points. I
argued that Muhammad from the seventh
century non-Muslim sources was real. I
argued that the Sunni Shia proof split
prove that his DNA is in action because
that's what they believe. And I made the
argument from embarrassment. It was just
those three and he wanted immediately to
debate me. Now, if you want to debate me
on what I just said, it was those three
points. And so when the debate started,
I wrote I made those three points, but
even, you know, more emphatically with
quoting um Patricia Corona, etc. So I
find it kind of strange for him to now
be like oh that's not the real Muhammad
that's another kind of Muhammad and he
just keeps you know and the criteria he
okay oh before I and his the point that
the first point he said is I have to
prove it right the burden of proof is on
me and also on Muslims he brought that
up during the debate and I and I think I
shut him down right away because I said
yeah technically speaking theoretically
it is but in this case Muslims don't
have to prove a thing to you Okay,
they've offered you the da to believe in
Islam, right? And people like you and I,
we believe Muhammad existed, but we
haven't accepted it. We think he's a
false prophet. Okay, ker infidels. You,
Jay, are saying he didn't prove to me he
exists. Uh, no, we're not going to
bother proving anything. Kefir, you're
an infidel. So, it's kind of silly for
him to think that Muslims are troubled
and they feel that there's this burden
of proof to prove to us that Muhammad
existed. No, they don't. It's again, so
it's a it's a totally inapplicable point
to even make. Um he's trying to bring,
you know, the standards of philosophy as
if Muslims are going to care about this,
and they're not. Um anyway, I'll stop
for a while.
>> Uh I I would also think that's that's
just that's just ridiculous. Um I mean,
think if someone comes along and says,
"Hey, Julius Caesar never existed." And
you say, "I mean, obviously Julius
Caesar exists." Well, prove that he
exists and I'm just going to play
skeptic. Well, if you're if you're
denying if you're denying an a major
historical figure, wouldn't you have to
show that you have some some really
great explanation for what happened and
how why everyone thinks
>> that's the point.
>> Yeah,
>> that's the point. The historical
standard is that look, we have the
records and you need to give me some
really good reason not to believe it.
That's how we do history. If it if we
start off from the first premise, which
is, oh, I don't care about the primary
sources. They're all lies. Everyone has
to disappear. In fact, I mentioned um I
mentioned Caesar during the debate and I
pointed out, you know, Caesar seems to
be very real because guess what? We have
his his uh his it's not his
autobiography, but his journal basically
when he was in Gaul and we have it,
right? And and Caesar is something like
whatever 30 BC, he's active at that
time. Um but guess what? The actual
extent version of the journal that he
wrote is about 800 years after Caesar.
So once again, if we use um J. Smith's
impossible standards, Caesar never
existed. Alexander the Great of course
never existed because all the primary
sources come 300 or so years after him.
I give multiple examples. You know, all
the Viking kings that nobody doubts
their existence. Uh Harold Hardrada, you
know, all all of them if the famous
ones, okay, guess what? They all come
from one guy, Snory Sterlson, writing in
Iceland about 500 years, okay? 4 to 500
years after these guys died. I've never
heard anyone say, "Oh, they're not real
because this is too late and you got to
prove it to me." Okay? So, if you use if
you use that standard, nobody comes out
alive in history. Everyone has to
disappear. And again, I I gave you the
Old Testament argument. You know, it's
it's it applies the same way. It goes
both ways. Um you can't just you can't
just create these impossible standards
and don't apply them to anybody, but
then throw them all at Muhammad. And the
more they're proven, the more you raise
the bar higher and keep saying, "Oh,
well, now you have to prove to me all
the suras were written." It's just it's
it it becomes ridiculous, you know, and
but that's uh they fall for that, I
suppose.
>> Yeah. And uh the situation here is uh
Yeah, guys. So, what Raymond said is,
you know, technically tech in a
technical sense, burden of proof is on
the affirmative and so on, but uh in
situation in situations like you have to
be careful about someone just shifting
complete burden of proof. Why? because
there's a bunch of evidence you're
trying to account for. And if you've got
the if you've got an explanation that
accounts for this evidence and you and
you come along and say, "No, no, no, no,
that's that's not the correct
explanation." Well, unless you show me
there's a better explanation, that still
is the best explanation. It's like uh uh
the new atheist did this. U back in the
day, atheists used to actually argue for
atheism. They'd say, "Ah, but the
problem of evil and divine hiddenness.
If God wanted us to believe in him, why
didn't he just appear to us?" They use
arguments. You got to the new atheist
and then it was you can't prove to us
that God exists. You can't prove it. So
prove it. And you'd say, 'Well, why
don't you why don't you show us how how
the No, no, no. We're not the ones
making the claim. You're making the
claim. And they shifted the burden of
proof completely over to the theist. And
then they just play skeptic. Guess what?
It's e it is easy to play skeptic. So
anyone anytime someone says,
>> uh, you prove this and I get to play
skeptic. I usually flip that on athe I
usually flip it on atheists when they
when they come at me like that. They're
like, "Prove to me God exists,
religard." I'm already thinking, "This
is not a serious this is not a person I
seriously want to have a discussion
with." So, I I will instant I will
instantly go, "First, prove to me that
you exist." Because I don't want to be
having an argument with a non-existent
person. First, prove to me you exist.
>> And then it gets real fun. All of a
sudden, they're like, "Who do you
think's talking to you?" It's like,
"You're online. How do I know it's not a
bot or a a monkey typing on a keyboard
just randomly coming to? How do I How do
I know? How do I know I'm not dreaming?"
>> Being skeptic is so easy. Easiest thing
in the world.
>> Yeah.
>> Easiest thing in the world. And it is
what it is. what uh Jesus myththers do
with Jesus. If you get into if you get
into a burden of proof and you accept
that and they get to play skeptic, guess
what? They'll explain everything, guys.
They have an explanation for everything.
If you listen to them, they'll say,
"Belief in Jesus as an actual person."
It started off with some people who
believed him as like a a divine figure,
uh something like that, and they had a
belief in him, and they had a cult
around him, and then eventually that
evolved, and later on you got to people
who thought he's a real he was a real
person walking around and so on. any
piece of evidence you can give them
they'll they can be skeptical about.
It's very easy especially as Raymond's
point to be skeptical about history and
so on. You can always make up something
and if you take the method of uh Jason
you can always make up a reason for
making up anything they made this up
because of this they made up this story
about Jesus because of that they made
this up because of that very it's the
easiest thing in the world to do. That's
why the new atheism took also because
you could train any idiot to do this.
You could train any idiot to go prove
that that's not enough evidence. prove
that to me. In reality, if you have
someone like Muhammad who's the center
figure of a religion and you have piles
of sources on him and you can trace his
stuff back pretty darn early, not as
early as lots of lots of lots of we
would love it if there were just really
really early sources on there. Um, but
people didn't always preserve writings
and stuff and later people quoted them
and so on. But if you're saying this guy
>> by historical standards, they are early.
If you compare across the board, they're
early.
>> Yep. you know.
>> Yeah, they are. And Go ahead, but
>> Oh, yeah. Yeah. I just I just wanted to
Yeah. I just wanted to It's basically if
you're saying no, at the heart of all of
this, as Jay was saying, I can't believe
what they what what this man did to you,
and I can't believe Muhammad did this,
and I can't believe Muhammad did that. I
can't believe Muhammad did. I can't
believe a non-existent man did all this.
Right? That's how we feel. I can't
believe a non-existent man did all this
stuff, is responsible for all this. At
the core of all of this is someone who
did not exist. Right? the the burn of
proof here is you're kind of the one
presenting a a crazy conspiracy theory
on this one. So if you think that is the
correct position, you have to show that
you have some better explanation that
accounts for the evidence even better.
>> But when we do that and you start to
even basically explain what are these
references to Muhammad and so on, you
start saying, "Oh yeah, it's about Jesus
and it's because the church fathers were
using this and it's because of Song of
Solomon and it's all made up and so I
can't regard that as a better
explanation." And so I'm left with no
I'm left with an explanation that fits
all the facts. And yes, the Muslim
sources can be weak. And yes, there were
fabrications. And yes, there were
exaggerations. And yes, they made up a
ton of stuff. But the explanation for
the core of the story makes a lot of
sense and accounts for the evidence.
Yours doesn't because it's all made up.
So why am I supposed to go with yours
and not this one? Oh, I forgot. I'm g
I'm being paid
>> because it's No. And it's also an
article of faith. Um but one point I
just want to really emphasize to people
which is that um the number one argument
that the nomos have okay is that every
all the Muslim sources are just uh too
late. All right they're they're much
later than what they purport to record
right and um even but the fact is this
is what they don't tell people that is
pretty standard for history. In fact
they're actually pretty close right all
right more often than not. Okay, John of
Damascus, immensely close, but even the
Muslim sources, okay, 150 years, it's
not that bad. I just told you the sagas,
um, all the Vikings that we accept and
take for granted are about 400 years
after they existed. And these guys are
much later than Muhammad, by the way.
Okay, so when records are presumably
better. So, I'm just trying to say that
the number one argument that they have
is really a non-argument in my mind as
someone who really understands the
nature of historical records because it
applies to almost everything. But they
play this game and make you think that
everyone else, you know, we have their
DNA, we have their license, uh we have
their social security card, we have
their teeth, you know, no, it's all so
tenuous, it's all so fragile, it's all
so fragmented for everybody. Okay? But
they want you to they want you to think
it's not like that and this is just a
peculiar weakness about Muhammad when in
fact, as I quoted from Patricia Cron,
he's actually pretty well attested to.
>> Yeah. And uh though it is this it yeah
guys keep your eyes peeled when someone
comes along and says uh hey you have to
prove this and I get to sit back and
play skeptic and just deny everything
you're putting forward at some point if
there is evidence that they're
dismissing. Oh maybe this maybe that
maybe this explains it maybe that
explains it.
>> Um at the end of the day either they
have a better explanation that fits the
evidence or they don't. It's just like,
you know, if you argued against the, you
know, an atheist against the ex, you
know, if an atheist arguing against the
existence of God and you say, "Hey, you
know, the universe popped into
existence. Uh, sounds like creation."
And then the universe is finely tuned.
Meaning, you know, the laws of nature
seem they're required to be at a
certain, you know, the the these various
uh constants and so on have to be like
just right or we wouldn't be here. And
then you have to get life and then you
need human consciousness and then you
need this and then you need that. And if
you say, "Ah, well, that's no proof.
That's no evidence." Okay. What's a
better explanation for how we got all
this? Ah, burn of proof is on you. Well,
okay then. I
>> and and this is uh you know in my early
videos and I think this is what really
bothered him. I I point I pointed this
out that you know what the strength of
the no mo argument is that non-Muslims
want to believe it. Okay, that is its
number one strength. It's appeal. There
is a demographic that does not want to
believe that that man ever existed.
Okay, for numerous reasons. That is its
one number one appeal. It's not the
arguments because the arguments are
flimsy. They are weaker than the facts
that we have as recorded by history. But
why are people gravitating to it? And my
point was that's the exact reason why no
Muslims going to hear it because the
Muslim starts off on a different foot.
They do believe in Muhammad. He's their
prophet. They love him. Okay? They're
not gravitating towards this argument by
nature the way all these non-Muslims and
especially Christians are. That's why I
guarantee you there's probably so many
no-nowers who don't even know the
arguments. They've just heard some guy
say Muhammad didn't exist. He has
letters behind his name or whatever. And
that's good enough for them. Okay. But
guess what? That's not good enough for
Muslims. And that's the only way it this
will even ever matter. In the meantime,
it's nothing but a distraction. You and
I haven't even talked about how this has
now become uh not just a distraction,
how it's become an actual weapon against
what we're trying to do, which is
actually uh confront Islam, open eyes of
Westerners and Muslims. and so forth.
And you know, to me now, these guys,
these nomos are more dangerous than the
worst Muslim troll and leftist troll
I've ever dealt with because they are a
cult. Um, so you might maybe we can
address that a little bit.
>> Yeah. Yeah. We're going to we're going
to check out some of the comments from
these guys. We have one more short video
clip and then we're going to check out
some of the comments from these guys.
But um um yeah, I mean just just think
about this guys. So for 14 for almost 14
centuries, Islam is spreading and so on
and eventually gets stopped from like
conquering the world and so on. And then
and then we're told a little over two
decades ago that just based on the math,
Islam has taken over the world. They had
the highest birth rate. Here's the you
know by 2050 or60 is this is when it
takes over France. This is when it takes
over Germany. This is when it takes over
the UK just on birth rates and so on.
And we're told, see, it's it's basically
hopeless. And then right before it's
just too late, we get handed all these
sources. We get handed all their sources
and we get access to the internet. So
that all these Muslims and all these
different parts of the world who've been
insulated from hearing this, hearing
what their sources actually say about
the prophet all the all their lives, all
of a sudden we get access to everyone
with an internet connection. We can we
can we can make a video responding to a
Muslim argument. It goes around the
world instantly. We get everything we
need to completely destroy
Islam right now in our time. And then we
start
>> always want us to throw it away.
>> That's what I mean. We start sharing it
and all of a sudden the apostasy rate
shoots up from 0% to 26%. In two
decades, Muslims are going around
freaking out about what they call the
avalanche of apostasy. They're the ones
saying, "If we don't do something about
this right now, if we don't stop this
right now, we'll never recover from
this." And then right in the middle of
all this, we get Jay Smith and the
noowers. Stop. What are you doing with
all this nonsense? Just say Muhammad
never existed. That's what Let's Let's
Let's pray. Let's pray. Thank you for
Muhammad never existing. Thank you.
Thank you, Lord.
>> It's just unfathomable, man, when you
really think about it.
>> It's really really really really weird.
Uh Ash here says, "Mo is like those
cringe guys that think they're saying
something super badass and everyone else
is cringing. Mo, I have the verility of
30 Zoot inside me." Yeah, he was going
around bragging about having the
strength of 30 men. His followers
thought he was saying something
different, but he meant literally. Uh,
was the Quran written by heretic
unitarian types?
Um,
not sure what you're referring to here.
You mean like the pre-Corran like people
like Jay and and stuff will believe that
there was the Quran before the Quran and
that this was some Syriak thing or
something like that? Yeah, I don't know.
Um, Dwood Raymond Ibrahim, have you
considered teaching in schools?
>> I mean, I've been offered, but um, I'd
rather just do what I do, which is teach
online and through my books.
>> Yeah. And that that was that was my plan
back in the day. It was Muslims who
derailed that. Um, we actually had a
Muslim who used to stand out in front of
the school. I was teaching at I was
teaching at Ford. I was teaching
philosophical ethics and philosophy of
human nature. there's a Muslim who was
standing out there and eventually got to
the point where like one of my students
showed up and said, "Hey, there's a guy
out there talking about you." It's like
and I and they were they had already
been calling the school, but now you had
a Muslim out actually standing out in
front of there. And so it was okay, I
cannot do both of these. I cannot teach
philosophy uh at a university and be
criticizing Islam. So either I have to
back off Islam, which is what they
wanted, and then just teach philosophy,
or I have to burn that bridge and just
say, "Okay, I spent all, you know, I
spent my entire academic career studying
to be a philosophy professor, but I
can't do that." And so I said,
>> "Okay, there are plenty of people who
can teach philosophy. There aren't
enough people blasting away at Islam. So
I'm going to go blast away at Islam, and
I'm not going to give them that power.
I'm not going to give them that power
over me." So I was willing to sacrifice
my entire academic career and teaching
career to blast away Islam. And then it
turns out I was just in it for the money
the entire time.
>> Same here. You know, I was at Georgetown
working for a P at a PhD at the Library
of Congress kind of being groomed, being
in 2007 I was on CNN, Fox News, um NPR,
all the leftist liberal things, but I
started saying the truth. Um you know,
and it just uh I already knew where it
was going to go and I was warned about
it and um yeah, but whatever ended up
good for me.
>> Uh Dr. Wood and Dr. Ibrahim, do you
think in the future there will be a war
between Islamic jihad and communist
China? Who would win? With whom with
whom we ally? No, I don't think so. I
think Islam's falling apart too rapidly.
>> Um, and I think chi China would crush
them if they ever tried to mess with
them.
>> Is that what you think?
>> Only only the West has to fear from
Islam because only the West fights with
kids gloves. Every other civilization is
not going to tolerate Islamic nonsense
and so Muslims don't bother with them.
They only It's the bully mentality. He'd
only push around the weak guy who gives
in, which is the West.
>> Yeah. And so that's why you had all, you
know, all the situation putting uh
weaguer Muslims in camps and stuff and
that they occasionally did a little
protest outside of an embassy, but
that's Oh, it doesn't work. Doesn't work
with the Chinese. They don't fall for
it. So, we'll go we'll go complain about
Islamophobia where it works.
>> Exactly.
>> All right. Last uh little video clip we
wanted to check out. This is um Jay and
Robert on the principle of embarrassment
here.
So much of your book goes into that and
that's what I love about it. You do go
through these references after reference
of where they have sanitized Muhammad
where they have made him look I would
say just like Jesus. They want what we
already have. They know that the world
follows Jesus and they know that why
Jesus is so popular. In fact, I have
said this. I just got done saying, you
know, I just done a debate with Raymond
Ibrahim on this very thing where Raymond
Ibraham um has said, why would somebody
write all these traditions that are so
embarrassing that the Muhammad that's in
them are so and I'm saying, hold on a
minute, Raymond, your problem is you're
looking at Muhammad through Christian
eyes. You're looking at and comparing
him to Jesus. Muslims don't do that
unless they're 21st century Muslims and
Western Muslims. uh for western Muslims
he is embarrassing but not for a lot of
Muslims I talked to uh they love the
Muhammad that's there
>> of embarrassment is one of is really the
only coherent argument that people who
still believe in Muhammad's historicity
can aduce but I think that it's exploded
if I do say so myself in this book in
light of the fact that it's very clear
that these stories were either
fabricated or adapted from earlier
sources about other people and folded
into the Muhammad myth by people who
weren't embarrassed by them at all but
who thought this is practice these are
practices we want to engage in and so if
we have our profit engaging in them then
that's the best validation you can have
for this activity
>> all right so that was uh their response
to and that is their standard response
to us bringing up embarrass emarrassing
material. Why would anyone make this up?
Well, life was different back then and
this was considered good back then. And
you say, okay, what's the records of
this being prized and valued at that
time and considered awesome? Uh,
well, you don't know that it wasn't
until it becomes a maybe
there was a reason for making this up
and we just don't have access to it.
Okay, that again.
>> Yeah, that would work if it was one
thing. when it's maybe this and maybe
that and maybe this is why they thought
semen all over your clothes is good and
maybe they thought it was uh it was good
to uh bang you know bang your adopted
son's wife and maybe they thought this
>> and I'm surprised he says that this is
the most coherent argument I've already
the most coherent argument is that
Muhammad is widely attested to and for
you to say no we're not accepting that
is basically for you to change the
entire rule and say no one in history
can be attested to anymore because I
just don't like it. Okay. Um so I don't
even think it's the most the strongest.
I usually it's my third argument, but I
do think it's very it's important and
it's definitely one of the arsenal. Um
but yeah, the only thing that you can
say is um possibly uh you know moderns
don't get but I get is basically the the
sort of you know tyrannical Muhammad.
Okay. Yeah, that's true. Arabs in the
seventh century wouldn't have a problem
with an authoritarian tyrannical even
cruel Muhammad. But that's not what
we're talking about. We're talking about
constant embarrassing si scenarios that
would have been just as embarrassing if
not more so, okay, then and problematic
than they are uh than they are today.
Um, and they just don't want to admit
that. And they're trying to pretend that
it's all everything that's embarrassing
is about Muhammad being this sort of
cruel, you know, authoritarian
sexual deviant. No, that's not it.
There's a lot more. And and again, and
the way that stuff comes out, the way we
see it is exactly how like you were
pointing out, you know, the older it
goes, the the worse it gets. And you can
see how as time progresses until it gets
and so forth, it keeps getting sanitized
and sanitized and it's sanitized. And
it's just a realistic uh development
than just, oh yeah, it's it's it's you
just don't get it because you're a
modern person.
>> Yeah. So we could we could grant and I
think we would grant Robert and Jay's
point to an extent that yeah there can
be things that they weren't embarrassed
back then whereas Muslims are
embarrassed about them now like like
Muhammad and Aisha. So that doesn't seem
to have been embarrassing to them back
then. It's embarrassing to Muslim
>> pedophilia was not a problem.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. So I wouldn't use that as a as an
example. I wouldn't use that to say to
say you see this is this is something
that someone wouldn't make up. Um there
are other things where we again we know
the satanic verses were embarrassing to
them. We know that Muhammad and the
story of Muhammad and Zanb u Muhammad
taking the wife of his own adopted son
and then having to come up with various
justifications. We know that was
embarrassing to them
>> banning adoption. Yeah.
>> Yeah. We know that. We know these things
were embarrassing to them. So, uh,
again, it's it's if I mean, if you
wanted to come up, maybe there was a
reason for some person to make up the
story about the satanic verses and
multiple different versions of it and
make up the entire history of this and
put all these different sources and
trace them back to all these different
guys. Yeah, maybe. Why should I think
for a second that that is a better
explanation than how to deliver the
satanic verses? Yeah,
>> because I'm desperate to prove no m.
That's why
>> that's that's it. All right. Want to
check out some of these. Uh so we got
the responses, ladies and gentlemen. We
got the responses from the no mowers
because um you've got Raymond and he's
actually arded argued against uh the no
position. Mary Harp has argued against
the no position. I've argued against the
Nommo position. And we've got the
nomowers
have responded in various ways. Um, so
let's look at some examples here. Here
we have uh the shocking truth is you are
a loser coward. Get a life.
>> That's the my video which I recently
made again um responding to no m.
>> Okay.
>> So that's uh yeah that's the extent of
their argumentation.
>> That is the decisive reputation if I've
ever seen one.
>> Let's check this out. Raymond Ibrahim
has gone full pro-Muslim here with his
belief in Muhammad. One more step
towards his reversion to Islam. I think.
Yeah. See, as soon as you start
believing Muhammad existed, you're
basically on a path to concluding that
he's a true prophet.
>> You're going to become a jihadist.
That's the next natural evolution of it.
Yeah.
>> Next thing we're going to see, Raymond
arguing uh, you know, screaming Allah
Akbar while blowing up a bunch of people
in the name of Allah.
>> Inevitable.
>> That's what happens. That's what happens
as soon as you start granting that
Muhammad uh, Muhammad existed.
All right, let's check out some of these
comments, ladies and gentlemen. Uh,
Raymond Ibrahim. Hey, Raymond. I'll just
keep reading these and anytime you want
to comment just let me know.
>> All right?
>> Because we have kind of endless comments
here. Raymond Ibrahim just just due to
be publicized his name but all his cowed
reasoning is not on the truth means his
account of study is also a lie.
Believing a standard Islamic narrative
without a bases
as per history.
>> Need I even respond to that gibberish?
>> Aha. Raymond Ibrahim admits defeat. He
can't respond to
>> this powerful
>> I don't even know what it was what it
said.
>> Oh yeah.
>> It makes me wonder, you know, when I see
this kind of written English, could this
actually be Muslim trolls who've
appropriated logically so the Nommo
movement and they're spearheading it
because it's the best way to hide
criticism against their prophet, which
of course, as I said, has always been
the Achilles heel of Islam. Or is this
just a dumb person who can't write? I
don't know. Yeah, the the thing is uh
the no mowers sound would sound kind of
exactly like what a troll would uh sound
like and so very difficult to
distinguish. But there's so many of
these guys arguing exactly the same way.
I'll kind of like assume that it's a
no-nower
until uh shown otherwise. Um Muslims
fooled everyone with these stories of
Muhammad. The name Muhammad did not
exist in the beginning of Islam in
Islam. Nor did any of the writers of
Muhammad know if he ever existed.
Muslims had to redact verses back to
force Muhammad into history. Raymond
Ibrahim is like a Muslim that were
brainwashed in a madasa. Raymond Ibrahim
trust everything Muslims write down with
zero historical evidence from Muslims
from the 7th century. Muslims used Jesus
to model Muhammad. the bad things about
Muhammad was to throw people off from
the truth and make him seem real.
>> What a way to think, man. Like, you
know, I used to be sympathetic to, you
know, believing in some kind of
conspiracies because surely nothing
everything isn't transparent, but this
just takes it to such a level of I mean,
so delusional. Um, you know,
everything's a lie, everything is false,
and it's just whatever I want to
believe. That's the reality of it. I
mean that's that's what that reading
that to me that's what it sounds like.
That's how that person thinks.
>> Yeah. And I mean think about this. You
have no historical s well you got tons
of historical sources. If you want to
say uh you know we don't have all the
sources the early sources that later
sources are quoting and and so on. That
that's fine but they're quoting earlier
sources. U but I mean think about this.
Then he'll say
>> you just trust everything Muslims write
down with zero historical evidence. But
then he says g uh Muslims used Jesus to
model Muhammad. Okay. What's your
sources on that?
>> Yeah, Jay Smith.
>> Yeah, Jay Smith said it. That's your
source. Trust J.
>> He's a historical source.
>> Yeah, we've heard trust me, bro.
>> He was there. He knows. Yeah.
>> Yeah. We've heard trust me, bro. Now we
have Trust Me. Trust me. Uh Trust Jay.
>> Trust J, bro.
>> Trust Jay, bro.
>> Yeah. Trust Jay, bro. Um and that's
that's amazing. But I mean, think about
this. It's any any evidence you quote,
we're gonna be super hyper skeptical of
and reject it. And if Yeah. If if Jay
just makes something up
>> or another makes something truth, it's
indisputable. And the only reason you
could even question it is if you're
being paid by Qatar.
>> What else? Obviously.
>> Awesome stuff. Awesome stuff, guys. You
guys are doing a bangup job here. No
mowers. Uh we have two of these. This
guy is offering nothing sensible. It
must be annoying for Jay. He's arguing
dishonestly. Very dishonestly. That's
about you. Raymond is
>> the guy who's presenting evidence is
dishonest. And the guy who's just
offering conjecture after conjecture is
honest.
>> Raymond is no Christian. He's a secret
Islamidi Islamist arguing Momo lived.
Okay, no probs, but trying to legitimize
Mecca and this is a insane. So you are
>> totally insane, dude.
>> You're a secret Islamist.
>> Yeah.
>> Well, of course. I mean, if you believe
Muhammad existed as a historical figure,
even if you say bad things about him or
call him a false prophet, you are
secretly a Muslim because J. Smith said
so. I mean, you already saw um you know,
he gave the prayer and he and he had his
hypothetical debate with Jesus and
Muhammad. So, anyone who does what we're
doing is clearly on the side of Islam.
>> Yep. Got to be no other way of looking
at things, ladies and gentlemen. can't
possibly be that Raymond actually
believes because we have a ton of ton of
historical sources and so on and because
we uh we have all this embarrassing
material that we can't we can't think of
common sense.
>> Yeah. Yeah. It can't be because of any
of that. It's just uh you know we we we
aren't persuaded by by uh all the church
fathers were referring to Jesus as
Mahmud. Uh we're not persuaded by that
because none of them ever said it and so
shame on us. We're bad.
>> Yep. Pray that Raymond may know Jesus.
He appears to be a Christian by
tradition and culture, but not born
again. And we we know this because uh
well, you didn't even accept Jay's
prayer
>> as authoritative liturgy.
>> And then and then great debate. Jay won
this debate. The Muhammad of Islam never
existed. Jesus Christ is Lord.
>> You got to love the connection, you
know? I mean, there it goes again. It's
that kind of cultic mentality. If you're
going to believe in Jesus, you have to
as a corollary believe Muhammad never
existed. And if you believe Muhammad
existed by coral correlary, you don't
believe that Jesus is Lord. And that
that's what this comment right here is
saying.
>> That's that's how it works. Uh, no, he
did not. Islam is a pagan religion.
You've got to love this. Did Muhammad
exist? No, he did not. Islam is a pagan
religion. As if Islam being a pagan
religion means Muhammad didn't exist.
>> Well, I don't I'm trying to reconcile
the two clauses. I don't get
>> Yeah. I mean I mean uh you know the uh
the Greeks and the Romans had a pagan
religion. I guess uh Greeks and Romans
didn't exist.
>> Yeah. Oh, exactly. Pagan religions don't
exist. That's the lesson.
>> Yeah, pagans don't exist. Um let's see.
Raymond Ibrahim is embarrassing. Where
does he get that nonsense from? The
height of delusion on display here. Self
delusion is dangerous.
>> Oh, you got to love this stuff.
>> Oh yeah, it's awesome. Raymond, if you
proclaimed to be a Christian, which book
is true about Hagar and Ishmael being
out in the desert, dry sands?
>> Well, I don't even know what that's
asking me.
>> I I think it's saying Yeah, I think I
think I mean, you have to try and figure
out how they think, but it's pretty
disturbing. But I think it's saying
>> I'm okay.
>> Yeah, I think it's saying um if you
claim to be a Christian, what are you
going to believe? The Bible narrative or
the Muslim story about Hagar and
Ishmael? Blah blah blah.
>> Oh, okay.
Let's see. In Revelation 12, Islam
belongs to the devil. Where did the
Christians go? Revelation 13:10. Mary,
please do convert. Oh, now we're getting
into stuff about Mary.
Mary, you need to convert here.
>> You see, it's an article of faith now.
All right. The mo the nomos, okay? The J
followers who are Christians, it's
become an article of faith. If you
believe, if you dare believe Muhammad
existed, you have proven you are not a
Christian. Okay.
>> Yeah. If uh
>> it's reached that level.
>> Yeah. Revelations uh says uh Islam
belongs to the devil. So if you believe
Muhammad existed, you belong to the
devil. And so you need to convert
apparently. It seems like what it's
thinking. But again, hard to tell with
these guys.
>> It's kind of it's it's not only hard,
it's kind of scary to try to enter into
their brain and thinking patterns to be
honest with you.
>> Now we have a few comments uh that are
directed towards Mary because Mary made
a video, ladies and gentlemen. She
pointed out that Jay's argument about
coins, which seems to be one of his main
arguments, uh isn't nearly as strong as
uh as he makes it out to be. And he's
leaving out a bunch of uh important
details like like there were there were
there were Christians back when this is
happening and they were bragging because
the leaders couldn't take the cross off
the coin because Christians would stop
using it and they still needed
Christians to be using their money and
so on. And so that doesn't for some
reason doesn't make it into Jay's talks.
He just presents it as hey there's
there's crosses on these coins. There's
no explanation of that other than these
were Christians. And yet we know that
Christians were bragging that the
leaders wanted to take it off and
couldn't because Christians wouldn't use
it. And so uh anyway,
>> by the way, when I was when I was in
college, I took a a class with George,
um Clyde Foss, okay, who's who, you
know, he was a kind of a big deal in
numismatics and Islam and so forth. And
I distinctly remember him talking about
how there's, you know, there's crosses
on the on on on the Muslim um coins
because a they appropriated the
Byzantine coins which had crosses and
often they would try to disfigure okay
one of the uh the arms of the cross so
it doesn't look like a cross. Okay. And
two, I've heard Jay um if I understood
it correctly, he's saying like it's you
know the word Mahm is on the coin
because um uh you know that's uh because
that's Jesus, right? That's his claim.
Or it could be that they're imprinting
the name of their prophet on top of the
cross because it's now it's their form
of saying Allah Abbar and we've
triumphed. We've taken your gold and now
we're putting our stamp on it. So the
coin argument, you know, unless I'm not
understanding correctly, just never
really made any sense to me. Yep.
Um, and yeah, I mean, even even before
even before Mary showed what was
actually going on, which she did, I re
recommend her video. In fact, uh, after
this, um, if I forget, someone remind me
to add the video to the description
where she actually goes through, um, and
shows what happened when Uman uh, tried
to I tried actually minting a coin and
stuff and, uh, just didn't didn't take
off. Um, but even before any of that,
just when it was the just when it was
the argument, I was just thinking like
like what I mean, you you think these
guys coming out of the desert are
obsessed with starting their own mint
and stuff like that? I doubt I think
they'd be more concerned with with like
doing the conquering and stuff like that
than they are with
>> Exactly.
>> with the with Anyway. But yeah, so I
didn't I didn't I didn't find it
terribly persuasive when I didn't
actually know the details. And once you
find out the rest of the story, uh
seriously seriously weak. Certainly not
enough to establish that there's a
better explanation for all the evidence.
Uh let's see. That's the problem with
religion. The books are inconsistent.
David Wood has always been a Christian
zealot, an anti-Islam. It clouds his
judgment. That's why I believe Muhammad
existed. The interpretation you give is
very compelling. Just don't consider
Muhammad bashers to accept it. They have
an interest in his existence. You catch
it. Don't consider Muhammad bashers to
accept it. Uh the explanation, they have
an interest in his existence. We need
Muhammad. We need Muhammad's existence.
That's what Jay's been telling everyone.
Let's see. Uh David Wood is afraid of
losing followers to you and Jay. So, he
has to poison the whale in my opinion. I
don't want to lo
uh
>> guys on what,
>> and this is and I think this is on Mel's
channel. Like, on what planet I'm not
being mean here, but on what planet is
Mel going to get more followers than me?
And I'm what on what planet am I going
to lose followers to Mel?
>> Um, yeah. So, not not terribly worried
about losing followers to Jay and Mel.
Mary just sent um sent us an email of
another comment. You want me to read it?
It's a good one.
>> Oh, I No, I got it. I was gonna put it
up at uh after we go through.
>> Oh, you got it. Okay. Okay.
>> Uh here we have it is it's because David
is getting money from Israel. Well, I
thought I was getting the Arab oil
money. Which is it? Which one is it?
Dang it. Please tell me. Um now we have
at the bottom, David Wood now gives vile
characters a platform. He's showing his
sinister side. Uh who's the vile
characters?
It's been Jai, Doc,
Thaddius, and Mary. Why? They're all
They're all my friends, and we do live
streams regularly on various topics,
>> but they're vile because they believe
Muhammad exists.
>> Yeah. And uh and they're criticizing the
uh they're criticizing, you know, Jay's
uh new new cult. And we must be they
must be evil. And I'm giving a platform
to them. And now even the worst of the
worst, Raymond Ibrahim. Wow.
>> Yeah,
>> I'm getting seriously terrible.
>> Now you got the real Muslim on board.
>> Uh, many years after reading Robert's
book, Did Muhammad exist? I'd go on
yearly church retreats with a Coptic
Brother. He hated what Islam did to
Egypt, but he was so invested in the
standard Islamic narrative. I have to
point out I'm the one who came up with
sin as abbreviation of standard Islamic
narrative. And I made it. Yeah. I made
it as st standard Islamic narrative
about the the about um what Muslims
think the Quran says about the previous
scriptures. So I abbreviate the standard
Islamic narrative and then I contrasted
it with my view which is that Muhammad
thought the previous scriptures
confirmed him. So he had no problem
confirming them because he thought
that's what they said. Um and so I
compared the the two hypotheses. But uh
Jay popularized it for this
interestingly. Uh,
>> yeah. And I and I actually I I commended
him and I was like, "Oh, that's a good
acronym, by the way." And you didn't
mention you came up with it.
>> Shocker. Shocker.
>> The compliment.
>> Yeah. Normally I don't even point it out
cuz I steal people's stuff all the time
and I don't credit them. So, I don't I
usually don't care when people uh steal
my stuff. I think it's hilarious and
awesome when I see people using
something that I came up with. But uh
how you going to use it to trash me when
I'm the one who came up with it? Anyway,
uh but he was so invested.
>> Let's all officially acknowledge let's
all officially acknowledge however that
I have coined no mo and nomi.
>> Yeah. So I I coined standard Islamic
narrative and I started calling this uh
stuff a cult. Nommo.
>> Yes.
>> Nommo which was brilliant. Now we had
the cult of Nommo and all these Nomos
coming out of the closet
>> uh in their cult. And uh that was
Raymond Ibrahim. So let it and let it be
forever known Raymond was Raymond was
behind the popularization of the Alz
story. That's when it took off everyone.
>> Thank you.
>> And I would say I would just say the Alz
story. My prediction is that just people
knowing about Alz just that one story
will be more effective than Jay's entire
approach will ever be.
>> Yeah. Yeah. And that's why I did it. I
was trying to show if you look, you
know, hard enough, you're going to find
stuff that isn't embarrassing because
we're modern and
>> not hard not hard enough in the zoot
sense. I just want to clarify what
you're saying, but go ahead.
>> I mean, just their name zoot. I mean,
you just you got to love it.
>> It screams credibility. Not like
Muhammad screamed, but it screams
credibility.
>> Yeah. So, this guy says, "Many years
ago, after reading Robert's book, did
Muhammad exist? I'd go on a yearly
retreat with a Coptic brother. He hated
what Islam did to Egypt, but he was so
invested in the standard Islamic
narrative. And in the existence of
Muhammad, he'd get angry and arguing for
it. I can never understand why it was
important for him. Well, maybe because
you had Muhammad who who who was the man
behind so much devastation in Christian
lands and when some dope comes along and
starts saying, "Ah, Muhammad never
existed. It was actually Jesus." And
then you know Christians started doing
it and then it took maybe you sound
extremely disrespectful to all the
people who are violently subjugated by
this stuff
>> and annoying.
>> Yeah. And uh let's see. They are unable
to understand because they lack totally
the love towards Jesus Christ. This is
why we don't get it guys. We lack the
love towards Jesus Christ. Only our love
to him towards our enemies and our
neighbors and self initiates light in
our soul. And this light of our souls is
needed by our mind to recognize and
discern what is said or written.
Continue your good works. This is
towards Mel because you see uh the uh
the uh heart by Mel down there. Continue
your good works while staying connected
with our savior. Savior and redeemer.
Only he can and will lead you into truth
as is written. So we don't love Jesus
and therefore we're not being guided
into the truth unlike uh Mel and Jay.
Hey,
>> if you listen apparently if you listen
to the Holy Spirit, it's going to always
tell you Muhammad never existed. So,
we're not, you know, we're not truly
being guided.
>> Yeah. It's just just weird how, you
know, God waited so long to share this
and then he used such terrible
arguments.
>> He was waiting for Prophet Jay to come
to be, you know, to raise him up.
>> Yeah. And to tell us all these things
about what the church fathers were
saying, even though they were never
saying it, and that Jews were saying
this and Jews never said it.
>> That's immaterial. That's irrelevant.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. What's what's
important is the story and your
unquestioning obedience to anything Jay
says, even if it's completely false and
insane,
>> right? Because this is a cult.
>> Let's see. Mary Harp and her singing
sidekick Thaddius are utterly obnoxious
characters. That's right. Because they
corrected Jay on the coins thing and
actually gave more information which
would lead people to think it's not a
good argument. And then
>> heretics.
>> Yeah, a bunch of heretics. Is it just me
or does it seem that ever since Aisha
he's been Oh, that's Muhammad Hijab's um
former hotel wife as he called her. Um
that's Muhammad Hijab's ex-wife who has
been talking to us to uh talking to us
about what she's gone through and some
of the problems with the Muslim
community and why they won't stand up to
guys like this. She's actually done
interviews with us. But uh this is this
apparently plays a role in something
about Thaddius. Let me see this. Is it
just me or does it seem that ever since
Aisha he's been everywhere lighting up
every comment section like he's
relevant? Embarrassing. And then this
might be the response here. Uh oh no,
this is not this is a this is a
no-nower. He says was fired from his job
in Ohio earlier this year. Dwood was
told he could not enter the UK because
of his felony record. Wood must have
taken down a hill fall ever since. Like
what what does me not going to the UK
have to do with anything that's going on
here? You could say that Thaddius
getting fired from his job. I mean, it's
kind of obvious. Yeah, Thaddius got
fired for criticizing Islam several
months ago. That's why he's been
everywhere as the second comment notice.
Is it just me or does it seem that ever
since Aisha, he's been everywhere? No,
it's ever since he got fired, he's been
everywhere because now he has more time
on his hands.
I would I would take that as pretty
obvious. And he, matter of fact, he said
that in a video. Wow. I got fired from
my job. Now I can now I can uh I can do
Christian apologetics and pmics against
Islam full-time.
Interesting. But nope, it's uh something
else.
Those who use ad homonyms in lie of
arguments are narcissistic attention
seekers. Really? You mean like saying
>> you mean like all these guys?
>> Yeah. You mean like saying we're just in
it for money and we're getting paid by
Jews or we're getting paid.
The best way to deal with them is to
ignore them completely. You could tell
them you said the kadesh for them even
though you're not Jewish. Attention is
their oxygen. Remove it and they die.
They'll just be left to posing tantrums
that will eventually bore their
followers. Losing followers is the worst
kind of death for them. We don't want to
lose followers, guys. And if we
>> talk about a bitter projection.
>> Yeah. If we if we if we don't stop Jay,
we're just going to lose followers. And
so that's why we result we resort to
nothing but ad homonym attacks.
>> This is insane. Yeah. Talk about
projection, man.
>> Wow. Uh people who love untruths about
Islam. I guess that's us. People who
love untruths about Islam will always
feel gutted that their sacred cows are
being slaughtered in the debates about
Muhammad, the Quran, and Mecca. Carry
on, Jay. You are an apostle of Christ
and male, too. even though you guys have
already split and can't get along
anymore because you're blaming each
other for all the mistakes you guys made
in your terrible arguments. Thanks for
your painstaking research. You mean the
research that he's already had to
abandon and uh gaslighting everyone and
saying that he abandoned it so long ago
even though it was uh it was July and
highly competent research dissemination.
>> Wow.
>> Before we uh pass the ad homonym stuff,
I have a little amusing anecdote for you
from Jay Smith. Oh yeah. uh when he
first uh when I first made my videos
talking about him and responding to
Nomoy
>> and you know all I ever did is just
mention his name like once and very
respectfully because I tried to put a
name to what this is because everyone
who would contact and attack me would
say you have to read Jay Smith. So I
basically said you know apparently Jay
Smith is the one who's saying it and I I
was like I'm sure he has his reasons for
believing what he believes etc. But
anyway, in his responses,
he uh him and Hatun uh they say, "Who's
Raymond Ibrahim?" And they say, "Oh,
he's a bodybuilder." And then um and
then Jay goes, "Oh." And he tells
everyone, "Yeah, okay. Put that under
your wing." Okay, remember first he's a
bodybuilder. And then second, he's oh,
and I'm also an Egyptian. And then
finally, I'm a critic of Islam. Okay,
now that's not an ad homonym attack. The
guy was basically saying that, okay, I'm
just a big dumb muscle head and uh so
what do I really know? So there's your
perfect example of ad homonym and how it
was used.
>> Wild, wild stuff. Yeah. So uh
>> which by the way amused me to no end. I
don't I don't say this because it upset
me. I say it because it was funny, but
just to also show that, you know, you
guys are accusing us of ad hominemum and
here it was actually at the at the hands
of your grand pooa.
>> Yeah. No, I remember articles from you
way back like 200 what 2007 2008 2009 in
that range that sounds
>> 2005 was my first published article.
Yeah.
>> Yeah. So I remember 20 years ago.
>> Yeah. So you're one of the OGs. So is
Jay there. You guys you guys are the
OGs. Um it's just interesting that I
mean I was reading your stuff way back
in the day and then it was eventually
someone's like hey check out this
picture of Raymond Ebri. It was a
picture from bodybuilding days and I was
like whoa. like on stage, right?
>> You were on a stage at some point,
right? Cuz I saw a picture of you on
stage.
>> One or two of those leaked out. Yeah. I
was a actual competitive bodybuilder,
but literally over 30 years ago when I
was about I won the Mr. LA when I was
19. I'm 52 now, so kind of it kind of
moved on. I still lift weights, but I
don't bodybuild.
>> Well, just know everyone the reason um
the reason you can't trust Raymond
Ibrahim is because his ultimate loyalty
is to bodybuilding. And if he um if he
rejects the existence of Muhammad, that
might interfere with his bodybuilding.
He'd be laughed out of the gym or
something like that. So um that's a
problem.
>> That's something like that's something a
no mower would say.
>> Yep. Got to be something like that,
right?
>> Let's see. Oil money is strong. Yep.
>> That's if you want to explain things,
guys, it's the oil money. And then we
have if I had a million bucks, I'd
divide it into three and give Mel and
Dr. J each a third. If God is for Mel
and Jay, who can be against them? Trust
God to bring the increase.
>> Biblical language for Mel and Jay,
right?
>> Yeah. If God is for Melan Jay, who can
be against them?
>> And uh how did we prove God is for them
again?
>> Yeah. Because I mean, yeah, they got the
awesome arguments about uh you know,
Jesus being Makmad and Song of Solomon's
and all the church fathers. They're all
they're all saying this even though none
of them did. But you know, evidence
evidence. You just have to you just have
to accept it and believe. And if you
question it, you're evil. Everyone,
>> you're you're just a blasphemer.
>> All right, let's see. It is sad how four
personalities with two out of them
hiding their faces.
It's talking about Ji and DOC. Uh, hey,
do you know why Jai and DOC hide their
faces?
Because DOC, daughter of Christ, is an
ex-Muslim
and her family, well, uh, she lives in
the UK and she's got a family and she
hides her face and so does Jai, her
husband. They cover their faces. Why?
Why would they Why might they do that if
they're blasting away at Muhammad and
the Quran, destroying every Muslim
argument? They are two they are two they
are they are my favorite two researchers
on this stuff. Mary's another one of
them. Uh they are all awesome
researchers. They are wreaking havoc on
Dawa. Why might Jai and doc hide their
faces
>> because they don't believe that Muhammad
didn't exist?
>> Yeah. So I mean just think about this.
It's they're hiding their faces because
Muslims would kill them. Why would
Muslims? because they are wreaking havoc
on Islam. But I thought what we're doing
is ineffective and that we should all
just be saying Muhammad didn't exist and
then we'd all be fine.
>> Saying it to saying it to Christians
too, not Muslims.
>> Yeah, they're actually critic they're
actually criticizing people who are
putting their lives on the line and
don't want to make it easy for Muslims
to recognize them in the streets. Um
yeah, shame on Jai and DOC. It is sad
how four personalities with two out of
them hiding their faces attack two
academics.
Uh, I just have to point out, um, Jay
and DOC posted their critiques and and
they hide their faces, but they posted
their critiques and Jay instantly backed
off and then Mel started going, "I never
said that. I never said that." And then
Jay said, "Oh yeah, we" and then he gas
lit everyone and said, "Oh yeah, we
backed off that point." So what what is
this? The two the two people hiding
their faces were correct. And so I I I
Ray Ray I I really don't understand
this.
>> Jay Smith and Mel J. Smith and Mel are
these champion academics. Why should you
listen to someone? The other people were
right and they were wrong. They were
saying for years they were saying things
that are false and they got corrected by
two people hiding their faces. What are
you saying? That we the people who are
hiding their faces even though they were
telling the truth and were correct, we
shouldn't listen to them. Instead, we
should listen to the people who were
saying things that were demonstrably
false and were exposed and they had to
reject them. You should still believe
them anyway. Are you insane? What is
>> un You're trying to unravel no mo
mentalities, man. Don't even bother.
It's It's impossible. It's You're
entering a realm of madness.
>> That's what I mean. And and and they
object to us calling this a cult. You're
a cult. You're saying we're loyal to
particular people and we don't care
about the truth and we don't care if
they can be exposed like demonstrably
for what they're saying. We don't care
about all that. Our loyalty is to Jay
and Mill. Even if they're saying even
>> Well, that's that's faith. That's faith.
That's a cult.
>> That's a cult where one J Smith have
more experience dealing with Islam than
they are alive. Well, what's his excuse
for getting so many things completely
wrong? Not to mention RA who definitely
definitely needs to start eating salad.
I don't know who this is.
>> Who's Ra?
>> I don't know. Uh and TMM
uh too many Marys who gives mother of
God and my mother's bad name acted more
like Muslims on chat on debate than
Christians.
>> Yeah,
>> maybe R A is me. R I think
and lose weight. Yeah,
>> I was thinking Abra. They might think
it's Abraham Raymond Abraham or
something like that. But I mean, think
about this. They act more like Muslims,
guys. Um,
what do what do Dawa guys do? They make
up complete nonsense. Uh, the scientific
miracles of the Quran, the perfect
preservation of the Quran, and then they
spread it, and then no one questions
them, and they spread it around the
world until it blows up in their face
and gets exposed. Who's acting more like
that?
>> Yeah,
I I'd say Jay and Mel are definitely
acting more like more like that. They're
acting exactly like Dawa. And then and
then what do what do DA guys say if you
reject their argument? Oh, you just
you're against the truth. It's like it's
like the Jews. They know the truth, but
they reject it. That's exactly what
these guys say.
>> That's the thing that, you know, like I
noticed with Jane, I wanted to point it
out is um what they do is they
vacasillate between on the one hand,
they try to act like we're objective
scholars. And then when that fails, they
fall back on faith and sort of pious
religious talk. And they just go back
and forth, back and forth, whichever
whichever is going to, you know, be able
to stand up. And obviously they fall
back to the Christian pious talk because
their their their audience base is
Christian. Okay. But it's like you need
to pick you need to pick pick one
paradigm. You can't just go back and
forth act like you're an objective
scholar and then when things get weak,
you start appealing to you know faith
and prayers and so forth.
>> Um oh I've uh been informed that RA is
not in fact you.
>> It is Reasoned Answers. It's Thaddius's
channel is Reasoned Answers. So yeah, I
thought it was weird. Someone is going
to tell you to start eating salads.
Like, what is are his muscles too big
and he needs to cut back on on protein
or something like that? But they're
talking about you, Thaddius. So,
Thaddius, start eating some salad, man.
>> I don't know why Thaddius isn't fatter.
I don't know what's going on. Anyway,
um, so let's see. And too many Marys
acted more like Muslims on chat on
debate than Christians. Like two raptors
kept on going and attacking other
Christians. Pick one target, one attack
while you write answers. Second, one
attack, meaning they don't even give you
a chance to respond. Insult, lie,
shameful behavior. All four got used
only to da drama. And now they are
starting to create drama between
Christians. Guys, are we the ones
creating this drama?
Hey, I'm live and let live, man. If you
want to believe Muhammad didn't exist,
by all means, do it. I've said that in
my first video. Um, but it's you guys,
the nomos, who are just violent and, you
know, just extra savage when someone
objects and says, "No, I do believe
Muhammad existed."
>> So, once again, they're projecting their
own ways onto us.
>> Yeah. So, think about this. I mean, I
can spend years. I can spend years with
Jay and Jay telling people that the the
only reason people disagree with him is
because of money or for because they
want clicks or it's just more popular or
something like that. And he can say this
and he can sit there using arguments,
some of which I regard as terrible. Some
of which I say, okay, you know, he's got
a point there. But others, uh, some of
the arguments I think are just terrible.
and I can sit back for years and never
utter a peep. And then eventually when
he's personally attacking my friends, I
say, "Okay, he's trying to bully them
into shutting their mouths. Uh, I'll go
ahead and and uh and have this on my
channel." Then we're we're looking for
drama. We're looking for drama and and
trying to cause division between
Christians. Not this not this uh cult,
not this cult that can't shut up. not
this cult that every time anytime we're
having a discussion with Muslims showing
them that they've been lied to about
their prophet and that he's a horrible
degenerate and we can prove it. The the
uh these guys come in. No, you're you're
arguing wrong. You have to just listen
to Jay Smith and just and just and just
say Muhammad did
>> go pray Muhammad never existed. Pray
about it.
>> Yes. Yes. Jay said it in his prayer and
you know his prayers are what is this?
Uh anyway, stick with Da. I'm a
Catholic. Don't know what denomination.
Mel Jay is Protestant and we're all
working together here. Yeah, Jay Jay and
Mel just scream working. Guess what?
They're not working together anymore
already. It it uh just think about this
everyone. Matter of fact, let me let me
let me put myself back on the screen
because I want people This is an
important point.
This is seriously important. I am
Catholic. Don't know what denomination
male is. Jay is Protestant and we are
all working together here. No drama, no
crap. They they for that four want
division Ji and DOC should stick with
one shtick and that is to translate
Arabic. Actually I only got one more
slide so let's go ahead and get this. Um
I think some apologists just hungry for
views. I see new short response from Jai
and DOC for this video. They clearly
only want to chase Jay mistake and not
interested with the argument itself. Jay
and Mel in other hand bring all
objection answer it in two hours bring
the data and admit that they make some
mistake and clarify it keep it up Jay
Mel and team don't be distracted by some
narcissistic apologist some narcissistic
apologist uh now if you disagree with
them uh you're just a clear a clear
narcissist
>> yet another projection.
>> Yeah, I just want to point this out. And
guys, if you don't if you don't pay
attention to anything I said for this
entire live stream, pay attention to
this part. Pay attention to this part
because this is uh this is this is
serious stuff here.
Jay's been saying this stuff for year
and he's been years and he's been he's
been getting fed this stuff by Mel.
And wherever Jay goes, it'll be an
entire audience of Christians and
they'll eat it all up and be giving
standing ovations and stuff like that.
Meanwhile, a bunch of what he was saying
was complete madeup nonsense. It never
crossed people's minds to actually look
up what he's saying. They just believed
it. Right?
And eventually eventually gi
up something that he was saying, right?
Mhm. is all the church fathers were
talking about Makmoud as a title for
Jesus and everyone is using this and it
was so common and so on. That's where
you get the word Makm. It was a title
for Jesus. They looked that up and say
this is completely wrong. There's no
church father who called who called
Jesus that. No one was using that. Where
are you getting this from? Right. Uh but
they said it much more politely than I
just did. And then Jay's going around
and even the Jews they would they used
Makmad Makm Ben Uzil. Makmud, Ben David,
Makmoud, they're all using They're all
using Makmoud
Giant Doc. Look it up. Put There's no
one who uses this. No one. Where are you
getting this from? Again, much nicer
than I just said it,
Jay. Oh, yeah. Yeah, we stopped using
that years ago. No, you were using it
last month. So, what's going on here?
And then, yeah, we've backed off this
because the sources just don't say this
stuff. And then, uh, Mel tries to defend
the Song of Solomon stuff. It doesn't
work at all. But, and then he has to
say, I never said this. I never said
that. I never said this. I never said
that. Then they have to split. Okay.
What happened? Why? Why? Why? Why was
there this huge fallout and these guy
and it blows up in their faces and then
they have to they have to throw each
other they have to throw each other
under the bus
because something they said was exposed.
Now, what I'm hearing from all the from
all the Nommo fans is
we should never respond to these things.
We're we're evil if we respond to these
things. So what we should have done is
let these complete madeup things
circulate until they became dominant. We
should just throw away all the old ways
of doing things, you know, just exposing
Muhammad. We should we should abandon
all that and just say Muhammad didn't
exist. We should all be doing that. We
should be using Jay and Mel's arguments.
That's what we should be doing. If we
did that and and we didn't respond to
it, we didn't correct it because we
don't want to cause division. We don't
want to cause division, right? So we
don't want to respond to people who are
saying completely false things. We don't
want to do that. So, we'll just uh we'll
just uh we'll just we'll just let these
things slide. We'll let these things
slide.
>> Let the Muslims catch it and embarrass
them even worse.
>> Yeah. And it wouldn't be this little
fallout. And I don't I don't know the
details behind the fallout. This is just
kind of what I've been hearing. I know
that I've seen them I've seen I've seen
Mel throwing Jay under the bus. I never
saw that. I never saw that. And then
someone said that that that Mel's no
they're no longer working together.
Something. I don't know the details. So
you you can you can you can you can
correct me on any of that. Um but think
about this. You're saying instead of
nipping it in the bud
where where if something gets exposed,
it's a guy who said it and the guy has
been shown that he needs to correct what
he's doing. You're saying we should wait
until millions and millions and millions
of Christians are all using this and
then let it blow up in the faces when it
will discredit the entire Christian
community, discredit all of Christian
apologetics, discredit all of Christian
pmics, and it shows that none of us are
looking into this and none of us will
call this stuff out even if we know it's
false. That That's what you're saying.
real good Christians would do. We just
let this we just let this snowball until
it's all of Christian apologetics and
this is our main palemic. Muhammad never
existed. How do we know? Because MMA is
Jesus and Song of Solomon
and it would just blow up in all our
faces and and all of Christian
apologetics and evangelism and and PMICS
has been discredited. That's what we
should wait for instead of saying Jay,
you said this, it's wrong. Stop saying
it. I mean, you'd really have the
fallout not just be between Jay and Mel,
but like all of Why would you want to do
that? Why? Why wouldn't you want to
correct it when it's just a person
saying something wrong? Why would you
want to let it spread to millions of
people so that everyone gets
embarrassed? Why? I do not understand.
But I regard that as a serious serious
problem for all you nomos who are
saying, "How dare you respond to this?"
You guys are weird, man. Weird.
Oh boy. Uh there was just one more there
was just one more thing that uh that
Mary sent over. Let's see
what's this. The new Let's see. This is
from psychedelic Elvis who says Muhammad
of the seventh century is not the
Muhammad of modern Islam. Muhammad of
modern Islam is a straw man construct by
Jesuit Catholic Freemasons to use as a
proxy to subdue the world's nations.
>> They got it. This guy figured it all
out.
>> We got us. The case cracker. The case
cracker.
>> Genius.
>> Yeah. Raymond, I'm going to I'm going to
go through uh super chats and stuff, but
it's uh it's we you've been on for
several hours and I'm used to going a
long time. So, if you want to share any
you want to share any final thoughts and
stuff like that and then I'll go through
the super chats.
Yeah. No, I think the main point um
which you and I both agree with is um is
this no mo business as far as I'm
concerned has always been fine if you
want to believe that. But it's really
spilling over and it's becoming just
very damaging and very negative and it's
just not even being used for its
original purpose as a polemic against
Islam. I've already said I even told
Jay, you know what, my belief is it's a
weak pmic, but by all means you and
whoever wants to take it to Muslims
should take it. I would respect that. I
would support that. At least it's being
directed where it belongs. But
apparently because no Muslim wants to
hear it or cares or is at all affected
by it. And because the no mowers and the
purveyors of it don't want to just put
it to bed. And I I get it. I understand
because they've spent so much time on
it. They actually found people in a
demographic that wants to give it some
ear, which happens to be Christians. So
they've gone there and they're welcomed
and it's become it's growing into sort
of cult. And yet it's not doing what it
was originally made to do, which is to
actually try to undermine Islam because
it's being shared only amongst
non-Muslims, specifically Christians.
And all that really does is uh you know,
all it really does is undermine things
because when you believe Muhammad didn't
exist, guess what? You're not going to
take him seriously. You're not going to
want to learn about his life. You're not
going to understand how Muslims learn
through his pattern, the continuities
from his lifetime all the way until our
time. All this is important stuff, you
know. So, you actually become
intellectually disarmed and you throw
away, like we were saying, you know, you
throw away all the tools that that
non-Muslims have against Islam. And then
on top of it all, it's bad enough you've
done that to yourself. Then your number
one mission is go around yelling at
other Christians about how they also
have to stop believing in Muhammad. Um
because somehow that's going to make uh
Islam go away because we're all going to
stop believing in Muhammad and pray and
and then that's it. Islam's gonna die.
So my point is I wish it had some, you
know, when you share it with
non-Muslims, it does nothing but
actually create mischief in my opinion
and I'm putting it mildly. Okay? So if
anyone wants to use it, use it as what
it was intended for as a pmic against
Islam, but just uh you know using it and
and amongst the demographic that wants
to hear this, which is non-Muslims and
Christians and then thinking you won and
exploiting that demographic because you
know now you're validated. Um you're and
you're really not thinking about the
repercussions of what this is really
doing. It's doing the exact opposite of
what it would do if you share it with
Muslims. you share with Muslims possibly
it could have some beneficial impact on
Islam but when you share it with
non-Muslims it's the exact opposite it
creates confusion it creates discord and
it creates intellectual disarmament
because you now jettison and throw away
all of our original tools against Islam
that is to say as I called it Islam's
Achilles heel Muhammad and his life and
I'll end it there thanks for the uh
opportunity David and um I'll see you
all later
>> all right uh go continue defending the
existence of Muhammad and uh getting
really really well paid for that.
>> Yeah, as I always do.
>> All right, take care. Thanks.